захід наша нарада але я хочу почати з
того що сьогодні я вже технічно
підключалася велике прохання Zoom у нас
Zoom у нас 500 людей максимально може
пропустити
ті хто Не спіть Не спікери будь ласка
відключіть від зуму перейдуть на YouTube
канал Міністерства освіти заходити на
сторінку Міністерства освіти і науки
України вони вже виступають могло
трансляція не йде вона знову повторюю
є великі прохання Вимкнути мікрофон
тому що йдуть зайві розмови в ефірі і
буде дуже складно спікером виступати і
паралельно чути
зайві розмови тому я дуже прошу всіх
максимально перейти на YouTube оскільки
спікери які мають взяти участь в нашому
сьогоднішньому закладі не мають
можливості приєднатися до Зума коллеги Я
вас дуже-дуже прошу ще раз про це
на YouTube Ми починаємо наш сайт
першому Олег Вікторович Щирецька
генеральний директора
позашкільної та інклюзивної освіти
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Анатоліївна Шановні колеги Дорогі наші
колеги Дорогі наші вчителі в першу чергу
Дозвольте привітати вас навіть в таких
нестандартних умовах але
включається до нас Шановні колеги
невелике прохання яких учасників
виключити мікрофон Ти реально зробити
вчителі
кнопочка відключити звук знаєте де
знаходиться
[музика]
велика прохання в мікрофончики зробіть
так що вони були перекреслені
чудово що зайшли можна Відключити
мікрофон
все дякую Дякую Ну сподіваюсь що є в
процесі ще не відключають Шановні колеги
перше що хотів вам сказати що буквально
два тижні відрізняє віддаляє нас від
нового навчального року від 1 вересня
залишилось зробити дуже багато Я розумію
що цей рік
стандартний можливо не всі вдалося
відпочити Не всі змогли скористатися цим
правом працювали дуже багато і попереду
знову таки досить серйозна ґрунтовна
робота
вперше фактично після завершення Другої
світової війни ми дійсно Будемо починати
навчальний рік В умовах воєнного стану
думаю що переважна більшість з нас
безумовно не пам'ятають тих часів немає
того досвіду цей досвід мене бували
упродовж цих
буреломних складних місяців місяців
роботи знаходили нові форми нові підходи
безумовно працювали над містом освіти
саме по змісту ми хотіли з вами говорити
Подивіться будь ласка Таке враження що у
нас ворог в принципі освіту обрав однією
з головних мишей у нас навіть нещодавно
зникає один з закладів освіти він або
руйнується або пошкоджується понад 2000
закладів пошкоджено 200 руйновано
фактично чем коли проїхали
[музика]
але навіть цих умовах ми маємо працювати
маємо працювати заради нашого
майбутнього заради наших дітей як ви
бачите перше що відбувається на
окупованих територіях це костріше з
межах підручників
нашого змісту освіти саме тому упродовж
літа компетентні комісії працювали
удосконаленням наших навчальних програм
не знаю я півтора року випускають вас не
пускають А я нажимали
[музика]
колеги
прохання прохання до адміністратора
ведення
технічної сторони нашої наради
відключати просто тих людей які ведуть
себе некоректно дякую пані Надія чи як
чудово якщо все було так легко зробити
простіше кожному конкретно відпочити
свій мікрофон і святкувати за цим ми ж з
вами вже скільки років ковід і працюємо
дистанційно ми не знаємо як підключити
свій мікрофон всі ж володіють ситуацію
всіх володіють цими програмами і так
далі Коли колеги
відключаємося все
Хто захоче висловитись буде така
можливість хорошо Так ось повертаючись
до того що упродовж
рік
до складу яких входили
Вибачте Олег хересько вас не чутно
вимкнули свій мікрофон випадково вибачте
У вас навіть чутно Дякую От бачите я
показав приклад чомусь якийсь правда не
всі
я продемонстрував що можна ж відключати
мікрофон хорошо Вибачте І так е-е
ми розпочинаємо фактично
наше серпневі конференцію наше серпневі
наради традиційні саме з найголовнішого
з обговорення змісту освіти
методичні рекомендації традиційні до
початку навчального року Ви отримаєте
сподіваюсь вже до кінця цього тижня
традиційно близькі Міністерства на сайті
все це буде сьогодні ми вирішили
обговорити лише ті зміни які були
внесені в програму Я розумію що для тих
вчителів які працюють на перший рік це
зрозуміло для колег які цього року
поповнюють ряди вчительства українського
буде трошки складніше Ну от спочатку
тоді подивитися кожен змінам а потім вже
будете дивитись загальні наші
рекомендації
звичайно особливу увагу п'ятий клас
п'ятий клас який
я думаю що зараз ми всі це будемо
слухати
повноцінними учасниками
українська школа
які 143 заклади які опрацьовували ці
методики ці підходи вже поділити
досвідом для них буде окрема зустріч на
наступному тижні і де ми проговоримо вже
особисто експериментального впровадження
шостого класу
на сьогодні
у нас буде можливість в такому
каскадному по черзі методів подивитись
послухати всі зміни перших уст і тут
зібрані сьогодні в інституті
модернізації змісту освіти фактично всі
люди які відповідають і це ці питання
почуєте послухайте поставити певні
питання можливо надостатньо певні вашої
компетентності
я бажаю вам успішно попрацювати сьогодні
Олена Анатоліївна вже зазначила в кого
не розстроїтись в кого не виходить Там
підключитись під'єднатися якийсь інший
спосіб до цієї наради в онлайні завтра
телефонний Міністерство освіти ця
конференція буде доступна для всіх ваших
колег вільному допуск доступі по
відповідним покликанням все це зможете
побачити і зможете просто переглянути
тому не розстроїтись кому не вдалося Все
Буде Україна Слава Україні
Дякуємо пане Олеже колеги я ще раз прошу
слідкувати за своїми мікрофоном щоб вони
були виключені дуже важко слухати
спікерів а Ми продовжуємо нашу захід є
надаю слово Юрію івановичу завалевському
першому заступнику державної наукової
установи інститут модернізації змісту
освіти п Юрію
Шановні колеги на порозі в нас сьогодні
нові навчальні рік дійсно ми сьогодні
зібралися з вами всі разом з нашої
великої педагогічною спільноті для того
щоб
розпочати обговорення тих нововведень
які є сьогодні у
навчальних наших програмах що ви Саме
таке питання ми сьогодні піднімаємо ви
знаєте що Олег Вікторович розказав що ми
починаємо дуже такий не важкий для
країни час перше ми розпочинаємо
навчальний рік коли
широкомасштабна жорстока агресія Росії
проти України коли зруйнованої
пошкоджено дуже багато
наших шкіл а частина людей і вчителів і
дітей опинилися в окупації або вимушені
еміграції
самі найстрашніші сьогодні це коли ми
зброю окупанта гинуть наші воїни
кидавали зруйнованих будинків впирають
наші діти але ми Незважаючи на це все ми
повинні розпочати Ну і навчальний рік як
ми розпочнемо його різні є підходи ці
підходити говорити ще на серпая
конференціях і тому в залежності від
того які умови сьогодні є у школі чи є
чи є у вас Місце для того щоб можна було
укритися під час повітряної тривоги чи
достатньо тих ресурсів для того щоб
розпочинати навчальний рік онлайн
офлайн дистанційне навчання і так далі
це будуть вибирати ці Навчання вже
конкретно кожному навчальному закладі
сьогодні дійсно ми обговорюємо дуже
важливе питання і для логічне питання
тому що ми з вами знаємо що ким і
військових засобів йде зараз наша армія
І наші воюють на фронтакт у нашій
інформаційна і культурний контент або і
ми називаємо ще інформаційний фронт який
не не більш важливий сьогодні тому що
дуже багато різної інформації сьогодні
отримують наші діти отримують літні
батьки і так далі і тому для того щоб ми
могли
донести ту правду яка сьогодні дійсно є
Ми повинні з вами дійсно сьогодні
поговорити по тих напрямках діяльності
таких крутих програмах які сьогодні
дійсно доопрацьовувалися допрацювання
програм дійсно відбувалися який
полемічній ситуації дуже багато було
спорів що вилучати що добавляти і так
далі тому що основні такі предмети ви
знаєте захист України основи здоров'я
історія України
громадянська освіта і так далі дуже
багато у цих матеріалах контексту
російського білоруського контенту і так
далі але ж ви знаєте що сьогодні це все
викликає глибокий біль і за і супротив у
наших серцях українців і людей всього
світу і для того щоб правильно
побудувати ідеологічне навчання наших
дітей Ми повинні в цій комісії
повилучали те що несприятливе не
сприймається сьогодні на нашому
суспільству тому що в період війни Ми не
можемо це розказувати нашим дітям і тому
тому велике завдання наш наш наші
сьогодні а особливо у вас вчителів які
Завтра прийдуть у Навчальні аудиторії
дійсно довести до дітей ту правду яка на
сьогодні є е-е і Дійсно я хочу
подякувати всі під експертам якійсь
допрацювали впродовж літа навчальні
програми тому що дуже багато було десь в
курсі але ми знайшли концерт консенсусу
в цій програмі затверджені вже наказом
міністерства освіти який з 1 вересня
буде дійсно вже по них можна навчатися і
тому я пропоную сьогодні дійсно таку
тісто співпрацю Давайте будемо працювати
ми ці пропозиції будемо в інституті всі
ваші зауваження будемо сприймати
обговорювати при тому що що в процесі
роботи ми з вами дійсно до дня до того
що 1 вересня ми дійсно хороший контент
або наші дітям і вже вже говорили те що
1 вересня дійсно на сайтах інституту і
Міністерства є Всі електронні версії
всіх підручників була така велика
розмова і з нашими видавництвом особливо
п'ятами ми домовилися до того дійшли вже
до
контент 5 класу всіх підручників буде
розміщені на сайтах інституту
Міністерства де діти і вчителі і батьки
можуть з ним познайомитися На жаль
паперових підручників першого вересня
п'ятого класу на жаль не буде тому що
війна і Кошти які були призначені для
підручників Всі пішли на обід але ми
будемо старатися шукати міжнародних
донорів для того щоб впродовж кількох
місяців частина підручників паперових
носіях уже попали в школу ті питання що
стосується п'ятого шостого класу Я думаю
впродовж всі до цього тижня ми будемо
обговорювати і разом спільно з вами
доходити до певної такої
мети для того щоб тоже і шостий клас
особливо 168 експериментальних шкіл може
розпочали успішно навчальний Західному я
вас Дякую що ви всі підключилися Дякую
що ви небайдужі до тих проблем які
сьогодні є і до тісної співпраці
впродовж сьогоднішнього дня дякую
Питання
якщо ми хочемо колеги провести якусь
інформацію
Дякую Ми продовжуємо далі І я передаю
слово Світлані Сергійчук
начальник відділу змісту освіти мовної
політики та освіти національних меншин
головного управління загальної середньої
та дошкільної освіти Міністерства освіти
і науки України пані Світлана хорошому у
вас
як Оце ви обставини
Доброго дня шановні колеги
Я приєднуюсь до всіх слів попередніх
виступаючих І дійсно хоче побажати вам в
цьому складному минулому навчальному
році
перш за все творчих сил енергії
оптимізму бути здоровими і вірити в нашу
перемогу
тобто я хочу присвітити питанням
програмного забезпечення
освітнього процесу
Перепрошую невеличка технічна заминка
[ __ ] чи ні
то вліво йому то впра
во
пані Світлана фіцайло у вас виключений
мікрофон
Вибачте пані Світлана ваш мікрофон
вимкнений ми вас не чуємо зараз
видаляють всі хто не вміє сам Вимкнути
мікрофон Зачекайте хвилинку
пані Світлана включіть будь ласка звук Я
перепрошую
я Перепрошую пані Світлану включіть будь
ласка ваш звук
Олена Анатоліївна будь ласка скорегуйте
нам не чути пані Світлану
з другого уроку
вибачте
починаємо спочатку
Отже
2022-2023 навчальний рік основних
документом що забезпечує досягнення
учнів
визначених відповідним державним
стандартом вимог обов'язково результатів
навчання є освітня програма закладу
загальної середньої освіти заклад освіти
розробляє свою програму
заклад освіти розробляє свою програму на
підставі типової освітньої програми
затверджено наказом міністерства освіти
і науки України але також заклади освіти
може розробити власну освітню програму в
подальшому її затвердження виставковим
порядку в цьому році затверджений
наказом міністерства номер 520 від 3
червня наказ який визначає порядок
проведення експертизи та затвердження
освітніх програм повної загальної
середньої освіти розроблених не на
основі типової освітньої програми
своїми виступі я буду торкатися саме тих
питань які стосуються програм
затверджених міністерством і
рекомендованих міністерством до
використання в освітньому процесі Отже
учні 1-4 класів навчаються за державним
стандартом початкової освіти
затвердженим 18-му році до цього
стандарту розроблені типові освітні
програми для кожного циклу навчання для
1-2 класів і для третіх четвертих класів
для кожного циклу розроблено по дві
освітній програми однак під керівництвом
пані Савченко друга під керівництвом
Романа шияна ці програми були
затверджені міністерством у 2019 році
Але в цьому році їх зміст був
переглянутий оновлений і ці всі програми
4 затверджені накази Міністерства від 12
серпня за номером 743
учні п'ятих класів
навчаються за державним стандартом
базової середньої освіти який
затверджений 30 вересня
2020 року до цього державного стандарту
розроблене типове освітня програма для
5-9 класів закладів загальної середньої
освіти вона затверджена наказом
міністерства 19 лютого 21-го року за
номером 235
Ця програма містить
типовий навчальний план і в якому
наведені
перелік орієнтовний предметів
інтегрованих курсів які Міністерство
пропонує для вивчення 5-9 класів а також
наведений перелік модельних навчальних
програм які можна використовувати в
освітньому процесі відповідно цього
переліку була проведена робота
розроблені моделі навчальні програми і
на станом на 1 серпня 2022 року 95
модельних навчальних програм мають гриф
рекомендоване Міністерство освіти і
науки України
перелік цих програм наведений у наказі
Міністерства номер 795 від 12 липня 2021
року оскільки цей процес розроблення
модельних навчальних програм триває і
досі цей перелік який був затверджений
21-му році постійно оновлюється і на
сьогодні в нього внесена зміни
наказами 5 наказів як додаткових які
вносили зміни додаток переліку і
збільшили кількість пропонованих
рекомендованих міністерством навчальних
програм
особливістю нового державного стандарту
нового законодавства є те що
Міністерство перепропонує не одну
навчальну програму для вивчення певного
предмету а варіативність модельних
навчальних програм і з яких заклад
освіти обирає саме ту програму яка
відповідає
концепції його освітньої програми
запитам здобувачів квіти громади
педагогічного колективу
матеріально-технічного забезпечення
до всіх модельних навчальних програм
написано підручники і як же говорити
Юрій Іванович підручник і будуть
розміщені на в електронному форматі на
сайті інститути модернізації змісту
освіти
6-9 класи навчаються за державним
стандартом 2011 року до якого
затверджене Міністерство типового
освітня програма
наказ номер 405 від 20 квітня 2018 року
до цієї типової освітньої програми
затверджені навчальні програми вони були
розроблені затверджені 2015 році але
2017 році оновлені і затверджені наказом
804 від 7 червня 2017 року в цьому році
Частина цих програм була переглянута
оновлена і надано їм гриф рекомендовано
сучасному світі і науки наказом 698 від
3 серпня 2022 року
10-11 класи навчаються також за
стандартом 2011 року
типова освітня програма для закладів
загальної середньої освіти третього
ступеня була затверджена міністерством
наказом 408 у 2018 році але звертаємо
вашу увагу що використовувати потрібно
редакцію цього наказу 2019 року
зі змінами які були внесені зв'язку із
зміною назви предмета захист числення на
захист України до цієї типової освітньої
програми також міністерством
затвердження або рекомендовані навчальні
програми вам десь пакет програм був
розроблений і затверджений 2017 році
наказом
1407 Але в цьому році знову ж таки
частина програми була переглянути
оновлена і надано їм гриф рекомендоване
міністерством освіти і науки наказом 69
8 від 3 серпня 2022 року всі програми
типові освітні програми навчальні
програми модельні навчальні програми
розміщені на сайті Міністерства освіти і
наука науки в розділі повне загальна
середня освіта є окремі сторінки
освітньої програми навчальні програми
для 1-4 для 6-9 для 10-11 і модемі
навчальні програми для 5
класів всі є вільному доступі і
розміщені як і програми затверджені
попередніми наказами так які програми
які були оновлені в цьому році і
затверджені наказом цього
також Хочу зупинитися в своєму виступі
на пріоритетних напрямах освітньої
діяльності у новому навчальному році Ну
по-перше за все це продовження реформи
загальної середньої освіти відповідно до
концепції нова українська школа це
провадження 5 класах і пілотування у 6
класах нового державного стандарту
базової середньої освіти це організація
освітнього процесу після вимушеного
переривання його звичного перебігу
викликаного спочатку тривалими
карантинними зв'язку з поширенням
інфекції коли 19 а потім з
військової агресії Російської федерації
на території нашої держави ще одним
важливим напрямком є психологічна
підтримка всіх учасників освітнього
процесу в умовах воєнного і
післявоєнного стану
значну увагу у цьому навчальному році
слід приділити
національно-патріотичному компоненту в
предметах інтегрованих курсах усіх
освітніх галузей але насамперед це
вимога актуальна для предметів
мовно-літературної громадянської та
історичної та мистецької освітньої
галузі
тема першого уроку в новому навчальному
році ми українці честь і слава не зла
міністерством освіти розроблені
методичні рекомендації до проведення
цього уроку які на цьому тижні не є До
закладів освіти враховуючи тривалу
широкомасштабну війну російських
окупаційних військ яка відбувається
фактично на всій території України
актуальними цей час є Просвіта з питань
особистої безпеки А за умови
використання дистанційної змішаної форми
навчання посилюється знавлюючись
навчання щодо безпеки в інтернеті і
безперечно вимого часу і формування
здобичі освіти медіаграми
корисні посилання для всіх цих питань ви
знайдете методичних рекомендаціях до
нового навчального року також на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки України і ще
одне один момент на який хоче звернути
увагу
у зв'язку з подіями які відбуваються
останнім часом на території нашої
держави
було тимчасове призупинено навчання
потім ми перейшли до дистанційного
навчання на всій території України тому
і в зв'язку з цим
можливі певні Як то кажуть освітні
втрати дуже важливо визначити той рівень
на якому знаходяться наші діти на
початку нового навчального року тому
Міністерство рекомендує на початку
навчального року виявити рівень
обменування учнів і навчальних
матеріалів яким вони володівали В умовах
воєнного часу самостійно або з
використанням технології дистанційного
навчання визначити необхідність
організації повторення вивченого у
минулому році а також запровадити
навчання більш детально про це ви
зможете прочитати методичних
рекомендаціях Міністерства до освітнього
процесу і викладання навчальних
предметів у
2022-2023 році в цьому році цей документ
має значний обсяг і крім загальної
частини яка стосується
всіх вчителів-предметників керівників
адміністрації закладів освіти є окремі
додатки в яких
даються рекомендації щодо викладання
певних предметів певних освітніх галузей
Дякую за увагу ще раз Хочу побажати вам
творчих сил енергії оптимізму здоров'я і
миру в Україні
частину про методичні інновації в
приватній освіті з нами поділиться цією
інформацією Ірина Степанська очільниця
методичного центру асоціації приватних
закладів України
пані Ірина ви з нами Так я тут Добрий
день Дякую за увагу будь ласка
Так я щоб супроводити свій короткий
виступ зараз виведу на екран невеличку
презентацію
так
я
так колеги Дійсно я сьогодні представляю
бізнесу асоціацію приватних закладів яка
на зараз налічує більше 250 приватних
закладів з усієї України це садочки
школи Та позашкілля ви знаєте колеги Що
приватна освіта це такий
пол eBay експериментів швидке
впровадження різного закордонного
досвіду різних інноваційних моментів
тому ми багато експериментуємо і
сьогодні я хочу дуже коротко буквально 5
хвилин але розказати вам про тренди в
методичних розробках саме приватній
освіті
так
[музика]
дивіться колеги в методичних розробках
методичних матеріалів ми базуємося на
таких ключових навичках які ми маємо
виховати в наших учнів протягом школи є
звичайно державний стандарт який в першу
чергу ми його покриваємо але ми ще
орієнтуємося так трошки футуристично
дивимося вперед і маємо розуміти які
необхідні навички повинні мати наш
випускник Звичайно що це не є секретом
так Всі ви знаєте там про топ-10 навичок
визначених на всесвітньому економічному
форумі топ-10 навичок 2025 року Так на
ньому І базується концепція нуш але ми
вирішили ще більш конкретніше з
концентруватися на них і фактично Що ми
робимо ми беремо кожну навичку там
наприклад аналітичне мислення та
інноваційність так і розуміємо які ми
необхідно розробити інструменти
цю навичку виховати в наших дітях і
фактично так проходимося по кожному з
цих десяти навичок зазначених
визначених на всесвітньому економічному
форумі Так зараз секундочку трішечки
підгальмовує
зараз коротко пройдуся про прикладах і
по деяких наших методичних розробках щоб
Ви подивилися як це виглядає у нас
приватній освіті Отже Для прикладу
беремо ми таку навичку яка зараз стоїть
першою в
переліку
давоса це аналітичне мислення та
інноваційність для того щоб розвинути і
прокачати цю навичку в дітях ми
розробили такі додаткові курси які
можуть використовуватись в позашкіллі
або вибіркових курсах це перший курс це
логічна та стратегічне мислення друге
дата Science третій Google Shift
Для прикладу дата Science - це реальні
початки дата сайт тобто так от за цією
об'ємної великої іт-сфери яка
починається фактично там ще з першого
класу дітям надзвичайно цікаво з цим
працювати Тобто це реальна робота з
даними прокачування
аналітичного мислення
логіки поглиблення математики і так далі
а так от виглядають ці вербуки вони є
двомовними першокласнички працюють Ось
так от ще на папері старші діти уже на
планшетах на комп'юторах наступний курс
який розвивається навичку Це Google
shapes так тобто тут вже ми вчимо базові
формули та функції Google діаграми
дажбоорди імпор даних які оновлюється
автоматично Тобто Це ті необхідні
навички сучасності які повинні знати
наші діти щоб бути
конкурентноспроможними далі ми вважаємо
що
конкурувати зі штучним інтелектом який
дуже активно розвивається Ми повинні
розвивати в наших своїх дітях мислення і
різні типи мислення Так ми повинні все
далі виходити від виховання виконавчого
типу мислення але концентруватися на
логічному та стратегічному мисленні для
цього в нас також розроблені такі
додаткові курси Які Так є однойменно
називаються логічне та стратегічне
мислення є спеціальні Workbook з якими
працюють діти на екрані зараз ви можете
побачити як виглядають ці вербуки для
пропрацювання
таких
необхідних навичок ви бачите тут є також
у нас креативне мислення Workbook
розвиток емпатії та ненасильницького
спілкування це все ті м'які навички які
зараз визначаються ключовими
компетенціями для
особистості сучасності особистості
майбутнього також інклюзивне мислення
окремий такий невеличкий курс
допитливість
проактивне мислення товаристкість це те
що зображені зразки наших ворбуків і
діти з ними з радістю працюють і дуже
ефективно ці навички в них розвиваються
вже з першого класу посилюються в
середній школі і так далі далі ми окремо
другу навичку так яка зазначена в там
серед ключових до восьмому форумі
навичка звучить як уміння вчитись
впродовж життя Тут також розроблені
інструменти зокрема курс лідерства за
Книгою Стівена Кові всім звичок
високоефективних підлітків розвиток
різних типів мислення 10 напрямків для
кожного класу про які я уже теж там
швиденько розповіла і емоційний інтелект
Ви також знаєте так що зараз
IQ вважають навіть не настільки важливим
як і кіо так як емоційний інтелект із
ними повинні працювати з дітьми
тому у нас розроблений курс там освіти
емоцій це курс який саме допомагає
розвинути
емоційний інтелект дитини курс лідер в
мені ось так виглядають Workbook
наступна навичка і те що про що ми з
вами говоримо і надзвичайно актуально
зараз це
спілкування державної мовою максимальне
пронизання всіх процесів в школі для
якісного володіння державною мовою і тут
ми державний стандарт посилюємо ще
додатковими курсами такими як публічні
виступи теораторство креативне письмове
та копірайтинг дебати це ті курс те що
вони швиденько вам проростає як вони
виглядають які абсолютно на новий рівень
виводять спілкування
і володіння державною мовою так
креативне письмо та копірайтинг виглядає
далі Для прикладу навичка ініціативність
і підприємливість так яку ми також маємо
розвивати ще в школі розвивати уміння
генерувати нові ідеї ініціативи та
втілювати їх в життя тут Для прикладу
теж вам розкажу от є такий курс
розроблений приватній освіті який
називається Ok Google професії і навички
майбутнього тут ми знайомимо дітей
Фактично це футорологія та
профорієнтація тут ми знайомимо дітей з
професіями майбутнього Так ми знаємо що
70% професій існуючих зараз найближча
десятиліття зникнуть принаймні так
прогнозують футорологи будуть нові
професії і вже зараз ми повинні
знайомити з ними дітей давати опис
професії необхідні галузі знань для
опанування тієї чи іншої професії і так
далі от тут я можу говорити дуже-дуже
багато але це якщо так загалом і дуже
коротенько пробігтися по трендах
наразі хочу побажати всім вам успішного
навчального року
незважаючи на все що з нами відбувається
ми гарно тримаємо освітній фронт нехай
нам все вдається Перемоги і на
військовому і на освітньому фронті Дякую
колеги
пані Ірина Дякуємо за дуже цікаво
змістовно і необхідну інформацію я думаю
що наші колеги які зацікавляться можуть
до вас звернутися і ви йому дасте і
методичну підтримку і матеріалами
порозумітися з ними дякую Дуже дякую вам
забираємо колеги я хочу звернути увагу
що у нас зараз закінчується по часу і за
тим що ми запланували
пленарна частина нашого заходу нашої
наради і ми перейдемо до секцій у нас на
сьогодні заплановано шість секцій вони
будуть іти послідовно в часі ви мали
програмку і бачити час приблизно ви
визначений для кожної секції тому будь
ласка можна від'єднатися від Зума можна
відійти від Ютуба і навіть його
виключити на певний час Якщо це не ваша
секція яку би вам хотілося взяти участь
послухати і так далі ми зараз переходимо
до секції початкової освіти максимальна
хвилинка дві і ми розпочнемо цю секцію у
нас модератори на всіх шести секціях або
працівники Міністерства освіти і науки
або нашого інституту запрошені дуже
цікаві
спікери які будуть і цікаво і необхідною
інформацією ви зможете поставити
запитання під час секції але я хочу дуже
звернути увагу і модератори і спікерів
секцій щоб вписатися в тій часові
рамочки які запропоновані щоб ми не
вийшли далі з регламенту нашого захисту
нашого заходу і хочу знов звернути увагу
щоб весь сьогоднішній захід А він у нас
сьогодні дуже тривалий в часі буде
розміщений на сайті Міністерства освіти
і науки України на сайті інституту
модернізації змісту освіти скоріше за
все це будуть YouTube канали
Міністерства інституту Крім того ми
попросимо наших фахівців щоб вони також
розрізали і кожна ассекція була окремо
щоб вам було зручніше будете необхідно
вам інформацію і можливо використати
Коли ви будете проводити традиційні
серпневі конференції з вчителями району
області і так далі використати якщо вам
це буде необхідна ми не нав'язуємо ми
пропонуємо таку роботу тому ми
переходимо до секції початкової освіти
моторатор у нас на терегині на
Пархоменко Антоніна вина зв'язку
у нас розпочинає роботу Оксана мука
Оксана Володимирівна Онопрієнко
доктор педагогічних наук ми їй надаємо
слово наших
Дякуємо
Отже Шановні колеги розпочинаю роботу
секція початкової освіти на початку я
хочу
познайомитися з вами з тими з ким мене
знайомий мене звати Оксана Онопрієнко я
завідувач відділу початкової освіти
імені Олександра яківни Савченко
інституту педагогіки на ПН України
Шановні колеги як в початковій школі
ведеться спочатку про те як ми повинні
себе поводити я Нагадую що ми
відключаємо мікрофончики мікрофон буде
включений лише у спікера крім того у вас
є можливість ставити питання в чаті будь
ласка ви маєте таку можливість
скористайтеся ним У нас дуже-дуже багато
інформації а часу дуже мало тому На жаль
ми зараз не можемо в прямому ефірі
відповідати на питання тому я повертаюся
до того що сказала про час
Шановні колеги зараз я поділюся
своїм екраном і
спробую вам продемонструвати про
демонструвати дані є моя презентація
сподіваюсь що ви її бачите це порядок
роботи нашої секції Отже першим питанням
колеги Підкажіть мені будь ласка чи
видно вам презентацію
видно видно
але дуже вдячний Я дуже вдячна вимикаємо
мікрофончики Дякую вимикаємо
мікрофончики Отже ви бачите що у нас є
три спікери і дуже-дуже обмежений час
оскільки перша частина затяглася відразу
переходжу до першого питання яке
стосується
основних акцентів у змінах до бокових
навчальних і до типових освітніх і
типових навчальних програм для
перших-четвертих класів
початкова школа упродовж багатьох уже
років останніх років стикається з
численними викликами ми з вами нещодавно
оговталися від змін у нормативному
забезпеченні початкової освіти всі
дружно перейшли на нові стандарти на
нові формати навчання у новій
українській школі і нас спіткала
пандемія Ми швидко переорієнтувалися
пандемія не встигла закінчитися як
настала інша біда яка за своїми
масштабними наслідками звичайно не може
порівнятися ні з чим іншим тому наш
згуртованість наша оперативність це
Якраз ті помічники які зараз нам
допоможуть підтримати один одного а
найважливіше підтримати вчителів і наших
маленьких освіти
так само ми на початку червня
згуртувалися в робочі групи і на
виконання доручення Кабінету Міністрів
приступили до
оновлення
типових освітніх і типових навчальних
програм
найбільше більше наша увага стосувалася
питань цивільного захисту а також того
що тих позицій які могли стосуватися
культури та історії
держави-окупант
нашою групою було опрацьовано 59 програм
серед яких дві типові освітні програми і
57 типових навчальних програм для
закладів освіти які навчаються або
вивчають мови національних меншин
найбільші зміни
навчальних програм курсу Я досліджую
світ або тих галузей які які
реалізовують цей інтегрова навчальний
курс була уточнена мета навчання були
відповідно до цієї мети доопрацьовані і
доповнені завдання які її реалізують
крім того
чильно увага була проділена приділена
реалізація цих завдань відображення цих
завдань У очікуваних результатах
навчання було уточнено
наповнення змістових ліній питаннями
здорової і безпечної поведінки учнів в
умовах цивільного захисту також було
доповнено зміст навчання актуальною
тематикою яка стосується вироблення
навичок
взаємодопомоги людей у кризових
ситуаціях вироблення досвід до
застосування інформації про безпеку у
різних життєвих ситуацій які можуть
траплятися під час воєнного стану
оскільки
ми в початковій школі і в цілому в
освіті реалізуємо компетентнісний підхід
до навчання
Дякую колеги Що відімкнули мікрофончика
оскільки в нашій освіті наразі
реалізується компетентніста модель
навчання то звичайно практичний бік це
особливо наша увага практичний бік
навчання наша особлива увага була під
час доопрацювання програм були доповнені
ті моменти які стосуються відпрацювання
без навичок безпечної поведінки під час
виявлення
вибухонебезпечних предметів оголошення
повітряної тривоги інших ситуацій і
на це
звертається увага в обох типових
освітніх програмах і в тих що
виконувалася під керівництвом Олександра
яківни Савченко і в тих що
відпрацьовувати під керівництвом Романа
Богдановича шияна
Отже Шановні колеги Коли ви будете
опрацьовувати такий матеріали для
підготовки до нового навчального року
Зверніть увагу на ці новації а також
скористайтеся тими матеріалами які
будуть вам пропонувати автори
підручників із інтегрованого курсу Я
досліджую світ це може бути в будь-який
спосіб там наприклад наша авторка
неділю нашому відділі на сайті інституту
педагогіки вже почала розміщувати
методичні рекомендації які стосуються
різних безпекових моментів про які
йшлося у програмах так само у групах
соціальній мережі Facebook будуть
розміщуватися і вже розміщуються ці
матеріали крім того я звертаю вашу увагу
що
всеукраїнська платформа вірніше
електронна платформа всеукраїнської
школи онлайн також розпочала розміщувати
матеріали так наприклад Юнеско надали
цікаві розробки уроки безпечної
поведінки в початковій школі які
стосуються мінної безпеки і так далі
Отже всі ті доповнення які були внесені
в програмах з курсу Я досліджую світ
вони мінімум пов'язані із теоретизацією
матеріалу із розглядом теоретичних
якихось аспектів таких загальних але
більшою мірою вони стосуються
відпрацювання навичок і моделей
поведінки у різних ситуаціях Яке Яке на
жаль нам
скидає наше життя
Крім того в нашій робочій групі була
проведена робота із надпрограмами курсу
мовно-літературних галузей так наприклад
у програмі із читанням ми звертали увагу
на тематику дитячого читання навколо
дитячого читання і посилені були в цьому
зв'язку акценти які стосуються
патріотичного виховання які підкреслюють
роль Визволителів України і посилюють
увагу до героїчного спробу нашого народу
у боротьбі із загарбниками і це
стосується програм читання які розміщені
у типових освітніх програмах а також у
програмах типових навчальних для шкіл де
вивчається А де або відбувається
навчання мовами націона розвиток меншин
оскільки Шановні колеги особливістю
наших програм є така
скута інформації дуже звужена інформація
В нас немає конкретики щодо певного кола
читання коло читання у нас відображено у
підручниках тому у Нам не потрібно було
вилучати якихось авторів або їхні твори
натомість у ваших підручниках тих
підручниках за якими будуть працювати у
закладах освіти Що у вашому полі
діяльності можуть траплятися такі твори
Хоча
я відразу хочу сказати що рекомендації
щодо вилучення певних
творів із кола дитячого читання можуть
вам надавати як автори підручників у
своїх соціальних спільнотах а також
вірніше у своїх професійних спільнотах в
соціальній мережі А також
ви будете покладати цей обов'язок на
вчителів вчителі наші
можуть
варіювати і вони зобов'язані
скористатися своєю автономією тому
звичайно треба відстежувати Якщо раптом
у якихось з підручниках трапиться такий
твір але я Звертаю увагу на те що під
час конкурсного відбору підручників
одним із критеріїв відбору було саме
проукраїнська така зорієнтованість
патріотичної орієнтація змісту навчання
тому навряд чи такі твори можуть
трапитися Хоча не виняток тому будьте
уважні і
варіюйте у таких випадках
що стосується програм
для шкіл
де навчаються учні мовами національних
меншин або Де вивчають мови національних
меншин то ці їхні відповідні програми
були також переглянуті і в цих програмах
були
вилучені деякі моменти які стосуються
порівняння культур народів порівняння
звичаїв народів тобто були вилучені ті
моменти які
змушують порівнювати українські народ з
іншими народами особливо із народом
країни агресора
Я
такі речі були вилучені із програмах
вони поодинокі але на жаль траплялися Я
хочу звернути вашу увагу на те що
програми уже розміщені наказ про
програми вже розміщений на сайті
Міністерства У цьому ж наказі номер 743
ви можете ознайомитися із пунктом 3 Де
зазначається що попередні затверджені
програмою втратили свою чинність це теж
важливо для вашої роботи особливо якщо
ви займаєтеся адмініструванням крім того
програми доопрацьовані програми вони є
вже вони розміщені на сайті можна з ними
ознайомитися і їх опрацювати
Шановні колеги це та інформація яка
стосується оновлення навчальних програм
Я хочу зараз звернути вашу увагу на ті
питання які звичайно завжди всіх нас
цікавлять перед початком навчального
року і
Звичайно вони стосуються того кола яке
входить до
інструктивно-методичних рекомендацій
щодо організації освітнього процесу у
майбутньому навчальному році
інструктивно-методичні рекомендації
готові Я навіть можливо розкрию якісь
вам такий секрет що частина яка
стосується початкової школи була
завершена ще в червні трішечки нас
затримували фахівці і основної школи
тому
ви досі не бачили цих
інструктивно-методичних рекомендацій але
вони є вони готові і ціна на сергіївно
сьогодні оголосили про те що вони
завершили роботу над своєю частиною тому
очікуємо найближчим часом і я вам скажу
що у нас теж такий великий за обсягом
матеріал 50 сторінок Сьогодні ми
презентуємо коротко з колегами зміст цих
інструктивно-методичних рекомендацій і
зробимо важливі акценти ви бачите зараз
це перелік тих позицій які висвітлені у
інструктивно-методичних рекомендаціях
Дозвольте мені відразу без паузи
передати слово але в Тині вікторівні
Лотоцький яка
оголосить вам про вступну частину цих
методичних рекомендацій будь ласка але
ти не Вікторівна
Доброго дня шановні колеги зараз
Валентина Вікторівна бере слово
Добрий день шановні колеги
Рада вас співпрацювати дуже коротко тому
що частина в нас немає і хотілось би що
відповісти на питання якщо вони у вас
будуть але чи не встигнемо Я тільки
наголошую на основних моментах які нас
очікують в 22-23 році це такі напрями
напрями освітньої діяльності як
організація освітнього процесу в умовах
очної дистанційної та змішаної форми але
керуючись обов'язково правом вчителя на
академічну свободу і від ситуації в
залежності від ситуації на місцях і
рішення
військової адміністрації ми в цьому році
посилення заходів безпеки тобто Просвіта
цивільного захисту психологічні супровід
про психологічний супровід Багато в нас
написано і зроблено в методичних
рекомендаціях там є посилання з якими ви
можете ознайомитись цілий розділ у нас
про це написаний і ви можете
ознайомитись можете подивитися і
знати як вам діяти з учнями і на що
звертати увагу підвищення результатів
навчання учнів перших-четвертих класів
засобів засобами компетентності
орієнтованого навчання активізація
національно-патріотичного виховання про
цей розділ у нас також цілий розділ
написаний методичний рекомендаціях З чим
ви можете ознайомитись з посиланнями і
до 1 вересня буде готова програма
варіативного курсу з патріотичного
виховання також Хочу наголосити що 1
вересня ми проводимо перший урок за
темою Ми українці честь і слава Незламні
Про що сказала Світлана Сергіївна лист
вже
готовий методичні рекомендації готові і
він на підписі на підписи заступника
міністра ви його отримаєте якщо він
сьогодні то завтра мабуть точно другий
урок присвячуємо питанням безпеки і
цивільного захисту в умовах воєнного
часу Ну оце про те що я хотіла сказати
Коротко і
залізними почули
Доброго дня шановні колеги Дякуємо усім
хто приєднався до обговорення
забезпечення освітнього процесу у
початковій школі у
2022-2023 навчальних роках зазвичай
серпневі конференції
святкові наповнені
наповнення радістю досягнення успіхів
обговоренням тих перспектив які очікують
учасників освітнього процесу у новому
навчальному році
однак життя
носить свої корективи і ми мусимо
сьогодні обговорювати робочі питання уже
було зазначено що міністерством освіти
підготовлені методичні рекомендації
однак Хочу звернути вашу увагу на те що
усі ситуації які можуть виникнути у
закладах освіти протягом навчального
року і методичних рекомендаціях
розглянути неможливо оскільки кожен
регіон має свої особливості тому
привертаємо вашу увагу до того що
керуючись автономією
закладу освіти що
регламентовано законом України про
освіту кожен заклад освіти залежно від
ситуації від питання яке вирішує від
можливостей
приймає
певні рішення управлінської на своєму
рівні звичайно
погоджуючи їх з тими концептуальними
засадами надання освітніх послуг які
визначені державою
уже акцентували попередні спікери вашу
увагу на те що пріоритетними питаннями
змісту освіти у цьому навчальному році є
безпекові питання тому хочу привернути
вашу увагу що матеріали для
реалізації цього питання
підготовлені як службою надзвичайних
ситуацій і в мережі Інтернет вони є
окрім того
є матеріали підготовлені
іншими організаціями в такі матеріали
пройшли експертизу і схвалені для
використання в освітньому процесі і
зокрема це матеріали данської ради в
Україні
матеріали відповідають вікові дитині
містять як розмальовки
систем цивільного захисту інтерактивну
гру є посібник для вчителя все це
зазначено в переліку навчальних
матеріалів на сайті інституту
модернізації змісту освіти ви можете там
побачити їх і віднайти в мережі Інтернет
окрім того Радимо
керуючих завданнями цього навчального
року
щоденні плани роботи вчителя включати 50
хвилині активності учнів
які будуть навчати дітей
діяти в певних надзвичайних ситуаціях
тобто поступово не нав'язливо ми маємо
готувати дітей до
того щоби забезпечити щоби створити
безпечні умови для навчання і для свого
життя
окрім того хочу привернути вашу увагу ще
Ось на що
2022-203 рік особливий не тільки тим що
освітній процес у нас буде будуватися В
умовах воєнного стану А і ще ми з вами в
минулому навчальному році завершили
перше коло навчання
учнів початкової школи за новим
державним стандартом і відкриваємо уже у
цьому році нове коло тому
логічним доцільним було
підведення підсумків тієї роботи яка
була проведена протягом 4 років і я так
думаю що в закладах освіти такі
дослідження
результативності нововведень відбулися і
ви їх обов'язково обговорите на своїх
засіданнях педагогічних рад водночас
хочу сказати що нами було проведено
також два пілотних
дослідження результатів навчання учнів
пілотних класів результати є визначені
як позитивні моменти які ми змогли
досягти
впровадженням певних новацій центрі
української школи І про них ми зазначили
у методичних рекомендацій це як окрім
того
виокремлені і певні проблеми
на які ми також повинні
зважати і враховувати
під час організації освітнього процесу у
чому навчальному році тому акцентую вашу
увагу на тому що в методичних
рекомендаціях є розділ про те які
методичні прийоми рекомендуються для
того щоб покращити
результативність освіти у початковій
школі пропонуємо і як учителям в межах
самоосвіти так і в педагогічних
колективах на засіданнях методичних
об'єднань обговорити ці рекомендації
адаптувати до
цій ситуації у своєму навчальному
закладі і працювати над тим щоб
певним чином ми все-таки йшли на
дивлячись на ситуацію певним чином
рухалися вперед і
забезпечували умови для того щоб наші
діти могли отримувати
якісну освіту ще хотіла би привернути
вашу увагу Ось на такий момент
покращити результативність неможливо без
якісної підготовки
вчителя до уроку тому у нас є таке
бачення І ми про це Прописали
в методичних рекомендацій
про те що у педагогічних колективах
необхідно визначити певні пріоритети у
функціональних обов'язках вчителя чим
забезпечити раціональність
ергономічність
професійної діяльності
фаховість і дидактичну доцільність дії
педагога про що ми на чому ми хочемо
акцентувати вашу увагу без щоденної
підготовки вчителя до уроку досягти
успіху неможливо тому
в роботі вчителя його ключовими
документами з якими він працює є
типова освітня програма закладу освіти
або освітня програма закладу освіти
календарно-тематичне планування
яким вчитель має самостійно розробити з
урахуванням
ситуації в класі готовності дітей
сприймати матеріал і на це ми теж
акцентували увагу в методичних
рекомендаціях і якщо буде часто Оксана
Володимирівна ще скаже про вхідна
діагностування яке є необхідним для того
щоб
календарно-тематичне планування дійсно
відповідало тим реаліям
який є у даному класі
протягом року календарно-тематичне
планування може коригуватися
залежно від того як учні будуть рухатися
вперед в опануванні програмовим
матеріалом окрім того
календарно-тематичне планування що має
керувати змістом
навчального процесу
має відображатися
щоденній підготовці вчителям по урочних
планах це третій документ
які є обов'язковим в роботі вчителя і
методичних рекомендаціях ми про це
зазначили що ці документи є
форма їх створення
опису це є превегатива вчителя це його
Академічна автономія це документи якими
він сам керується перевіряти контролю
вони не підлягають Але для того щоб
вчитель дійсно ніс відповідальність за
те що він робить як перед собою і як
перед учнем перед дитиною як його перед
його батьками і дійсно і звичайно
відповідальність перед суспільством
оскільки
покладаються на вчителя
певна певні обов'язки що щодо того щоби
наші діти отримували відносну світу
вчитель має
один документом обов'язково працювати
все звичайно зараз короткий термін
неохотуш що ми вам запропонували в
методичних рекомендаціях ми обов'язково
з ними познайомитися
опрацюєте обговорите І адаптує це до
умов у яких ви працюєте
єдине Хотіла би зробити ремарку щодо
щодо до чого
зміни в типових освітніх програмах що
стосуються
мовно-літературної галузі і
Кола читання є таке бачення що ви можете
реалізувати ці зміни через уроки
позакласного читання і
героїко-тематику героїко-патріотичного
спрямування саме на цих уроках
опрацьовувати
ще
ми отримаємо багато телефонних Запитів
як від колективів педагогічних так і
відокремих вчителів щодо вибору освітніх
програм і щодо зміни їх протягом терміну
навчання
протягом 4 років то
хоче акцентувати увагу на тому що
відповідно до закону початкова освіта
має два цикли навчання тому вибір
програми здійснюється Перед кожним
циклом навчання і цим ви можете
керуватися
зрештою питань Знайомтесь в наших
методичних рекомендація ми внучки ми
конструктивні у спілкуванні з вами
тому
звертайтеся вирішуйте питання на
місцевому рівні чи ми зможемо ми
звичайно
допоможемо тому усім витримки сили і
правильних До речі
рішень для того щоб ми дійсно могли
надавати дітям гідно якісно початкову
освіту Дякую усім за увагу і якщо ми
маємо ще декілька хвилин то звичайно є в
нас час є то Звичайно хотілося
привернути вашу увагу до проблеми
вхідного запитань вхідного
діагностування яке має стати основою
розроблення
календарно-тематичного плану Оксана
володимирівно ви долучаєтесь так так
Шановні колеги
Дякую Наталія Євгенівна я підхоплюю
слово ми працюємо оперативно і в мене ще
є трішки часу щоб ознайомити нашу
спільноту із таким важливим акцентом у
наступному навчальному році який буде
розпочинатися із вхідного діагностування
Ну я думаю що всім нам зрозуміло чим
зумовлено проведення вхідного
діагностування і я хочу повідомити що
влітку нашим відділом проводилося
дослідження ми охопили опитуванням
вчителів всіх регіонів України в тому
числі тих що перебувають під окупацією і
результати цього опитування засвідчили
що організація освітнього процесу під
час військових дій після 24 лютого була
неоднорідною і здебільшого Звичайно що
вона залежала від ступеню ураження
війною військовими діями певної
території така відмінність безумовно
вплинула на
навчання який був обраний на міру
охоплення учнями учнів які могли
продовжити навчання в такій ситуації на
доступ учнів і вчителів до
навчально-методичного забезпечення до
технічних засобів навчання такі складні
обставини вони призвели до того що
одержали на кінець навчального року
надзвичайно строкату картину яка
відображає успішність учнів у опануванні
навчального змісту в певний рік навчання
так наприклад 32% учителів зазначили що
вони цілком засвоїли разом із учнями у
їхні учні цілком засвоїли навчальний
матеріал
62,5% вчителів зазначили що їхні учні
засвоїли навчальний матеріал частково
решта вчителів
засвідчили те що вони не змогли
внаслідок окупації завер це повноцінно
логічно завершити навчальний рік і тому
рік наступний і починаємо із складного
діагностування щоб з'ясувати на якому
етапі свого розвитку навчального
розвитку зупинилися кожну конкретна
дитина і
відповідно до результатів вхідного
діагностування ми будемо здійснювати
календарне планування ви в
інструктивно-методичних матеріалах
побачите таку фразу що календарно
планування є живим і от саме живим тому
що воно має варіювати залежно від того
наскільки діти готові до сприйняття
навчального матеріалу таким чином щоб
допомогти вчителям Ми шукали різні
рішення і прийшли до висновку що
універсальних рішень тут буде не може
тому що як я вже зазначила дуже строката
картина успішності дітей і якби міри
засвоє тому ми навчального матеріалу
тому у
інструктивно-методичних матеріалах ми в
плані допомоги
зазначили таблиці в яких показали ті
визначальні для наступного навчального
року результати які могли повинні бути
були засвоєні у попередній рік навчання
Тобто Це ті стартові позиції від яких в
наступному навчальному році ми повинні
відштовхуватися і ось ці орієнтири вони
якраз і наводять нас на Ті
теми які підлягають на тій на той
навчальний зміст Який підлягає
діагностуванню для
того щоб більше мати уявлення про вхідне
діагностування якщо є потреба ви можете
скористатися
посібником ви можете скористатися нашими
матеріалами які Ми розміщуємо на сайті
нашого відділу і будемо надалі
розміщувати але коротко я хочу від
нашого відділу поділитися такою
пропозицією ми рекомендуємо
використовувати систему різнорівневих
завдань як таку систему реалізовувати це
буде вибір кожного вчителя окремо в
кожній окремій ситуації яка буде у його
класі і це можуть бути і окремі уроки
повторення навчального матеріалу так
наприклад навчання змістові лінії
математичних галузі вони реалізуються
наскрізно тому доцільно окремі уроки
приділяти
діагностуванню окремих умінь Так
наприклад
що стосується навчальних залишкових
результатів з читання то діагностувати
їх можна
логічно
вплітаючи в канву уроку певні
діагностувальні завдання і так далі А на
чому ми наполягаємо так на тому щоб ці
завдання були різнорівновими не тому що
різний рівень складності посильно дітям
а для того щоб дізнатися на якому етапі
Ми повинні зупинитися і в якого етапу
далі відштовхуватися я наведу конкретне
абсолютно приклад ось математика на
початку четвертого класу ми пропонуємо
на уроці на якому ми будемо повторювати
матеріал що стосується алгебраїчних
пропедеврівки ми будемо діагностувати
уміння розв’язувати прості рівняння щоб
повинно бути сформованим у попередній
рік навчання тобто в третьому класі
перше завдання ви бачите завдання
абсолютно репродуктивного рівня і якщо
учні далі не зможуть виконати наступні
завдання Окрім цього це буде свідчити
про те що всю тему треба опрацьовувати
зановом наступне завдання на цьому ж
уроці ми можемо запропонувати рівня
розуміння коли дитина повинна на
конкретних прикладах відтворити алгоритм
розв'язування і простого рівняння якщо
дитина не зможе далі сподобатися не
зможе виконати більш складні завдання це
означатиме що цю тему треба ще
доопрацювати певний час треба
попрацювати над розв'язуванням простих
рівнянь Повторити ще раз засвоїти його
алгоритм І що дуже важливо
визначити чи з'ясували діти основи в
даному випадку основи розв'язування
рівнянь є взаємозв'язки між результатом
і компонентами арифметичних дій якщо
Діти зможуть виконати наступні завдання
наступне завдання Воно трішечки змінює
навчальну ситуацію але його успішне
виконання засвідчує те що діти достатньо
засвоїли цей матеріал і ми далі можемо
запланованим раніше маршрутом рухатися у
четвертому класі Ну звичайно Можливо
десь Бог знайдуться учні які
творче завдання виконати це свідчить
буде про те що Таким дітям в класі
необхідно приділити особливу увагу
Можливо навіть вибудувати їхнього
траєкторію У подальшому вивченні саме
цієї теми Ось на такому конкретному
прикладі ми показали що оця поетапність
оця зміна складності завдань Вона
дозволяє визначити з якого старту ми
будемо далі рухатися
Я
хочу звернути вашу увагу що всі ці
матеріали Ми подаємо вони є в
електронному вигляді ви їх можете
відшукати в інтернеті їх замовити тим з
фрагментами цих посібників вільно можна
ознайомитися в електронній бібліотеці на
ПН будь ласка користуйтеся і ми будемо
щиро ділитися ними такими матеріалами на
сторінках у фейсбуку на сторінках нашого
відділу я
користуючись нагодою хочу
запросити всіх авторів
навчально-методичних видань також
підтримати вчителів своїми розробками
щоб їм легше було користуватися і
організувати Тому цей початок стартовий
момент тому що від нього далі буде
залежати і укладання календарного плану
і буде залежати успішність нашого
освітнього процесу насамкінець Я хочу
побажати всім триматися берегти себе
берегти свої родини берегти своїх учнів
і я думаю що ми достойно вистояли з вами
на попередніх етапах і я думаю що ми не
схибимо І в цей складний час
Шановні колеги ми абсолютно вклалися у
наш час ми можемо зараз приділити певний
якусь долю тих хвилин відповідям на
запитання у чаті будь ласка Я запрошую
але в тину Вікторівна далі євгенівну
познайомитися із чатом і можливо
відповісти на деякі запитання Дякую вам
були
Оксана Володимирівна на деякі ми вже
відповіли є питання вашої презентації
просить поділитися люди і багато
запитань от пишуть дописувачка Ірина
багато запитань щодо початку навчального
року у першому класі а які саме
запитання
[музика]
що стосується
презентації то я її виставлю з вашого
дозволу виставлю її на
групі відділ початкової освіти імені
Олександра яківни Савченко у фейсбуку
будь ласка користуйтеся я не обіцяю що
це зроблю відразу зараз тому що тоді
внесу деякі свої коментарі під слайдами
щоб легше було опрацьовувати цю
презентацію
стосовно першого класу додамо таке
ситуація щодо організації освітнього
процесу у кожному конкретному класі
вирішується на місцях Тобто ми не можемо
дати певні централізовані якісь вказівки
для всієї України зараз життя змушує нас
корегувати кожному свою роботу на місці
залежно від ситуації і також я хочу
привернути вашу увагу до того що
на сайті інституту модернізації змісту
освіти функціонує електронна бібліотека
в ній розміщені PDF
форматі усі підручники для
перших-четвертих класів тому їх можна
використовувати
для дистанційного навчання
якщо інтернету немає підручників можна
скачати на флешку тобто
забезпечити освітній процес можна окрім
підручників на сайті є цільний ряд
навчально-методичних посібників з
актуальних тем організації освітнього
процесу один із таких
презентації Оксани Володимирівни був що
стосується оцінювання результатів
навчання учнів так само є розкриті
посібниках і інші проблеми тому
користуйтесь будь ласка ними вивчайте
вони дійсно нададуть певні орієнтири для
підвищення якості
якщо
запитань є питання чи повинен вчитель
показувати щоденний план на вимоги
керівника
щодо цього то
керуватись треба здоровим глуздом є
певні функціональні обов'язки у
керівників як функціональні обов'язки у
педагогічних працівників
на мій погляд в умовах демократичної
школи то
в першу чергу
дивимося урок вчителя і якщо він
деякою мірою вийшов методично
недостатньо методично
досконалий то в цьому випадку керівник
Може попросити план уроку вчителя для
того щоб вчитель прокомендував свої своє
проектування цього уроку чи заняття і з
тією метою щоб можна було вчителю надати
певні рекомендації Тобто ми маємо
працювати таким чином щоб удосконалювати
освітній процес і допомагати один одному
в різних ситуаціях Оскільки ми розуміємо
що
підготовлені з вчителя є різною і
а забезпечувати якість Ми повинні і
функціонал керівника закладу освіти
є обов'язок
відстежувати та коригувати цей процес
Тому треба чисто на таких дипломатичних
дружніх стосунках відпрацьовувати ці
питання як навчити дитина у нас одна
хвилинка навіть Уже немає як навчити
дитину першого класу писати дистанційно
а далі і читати а читати
Шановні колеги ми всі ці проблеми
розуміємо
тому
країна поставлена в такі умови що
необхідно виходити із ситуації кожен
виходить з тих можливостей які має
пробуємо направляємо освіту дітей
дистанційному режимі будуть умови очного
навчання будемо доопрацьовувати
це
той результат який отримали тому всім
витримки
розуміння ситуації
доброзичливості у вирішенні будь-яких
проблемних питань
цілковитої повної взаємодії з батьками у
вирішенні питання тобто оцей трикутник
вчитель учень батьки Він має зараз
працювати
дуже сильно тому що дитина одна
і ми
колективно ми разом Маємо зробити все
щоб вона навіть в таких умовах
отримувала певний розбір
Дякуємо усім зауважень
наші
контакти відкриті тому якщо виникатимуть
питання звертайтеся будемо вирішувати їх
оперативно для того щоб освітній процес
у початковій школі рухався Дякуємо усім
за увагу і передаємо слово
наступний секції
це буде працювати зараз мабуть у нас
підкоплять але це будуть фахівці із
захисту Вітчизни
України захисту України основи здоров'я
і ми слово олені Анатоліївні Дубовик
передаємо правильно я скерувалася
Шановні колеги милон дуже вдячні ми з
вами слідкували Ви їх нашу наш екрана
було дуже цікаво було дуже змістовно Я
думаю що всі вчителі які вас слухали
підтримують нашу думку і потім
скористається всіма вашими порадами і я
прошу
вчителів початкової школи відключитися у
нас зараз ну 500 людей у нас пікери
наступної секції не можуть приєднатися
Дякуємо дуже бажано побачимо що люди
виходять Ми дуже
вдячністю
вчителів
захисту України основи здоров'я
ще раз Звертаю увагу вимикайте мікрофони
і де загальний шумність Давай я
подключаю Скрытая фигня вона
наказывается в зоне спілкуватися добре
колеги вимикаємо мікрофони
[музика]
колеги ми продовжу
ємо нараду
тут зараз до нас приєднався ми Щиро
дякуємо вчителям початкової школи які
вже закінчили свою секцію і ми просимо
від'єднатися бо дуже багато у нас
приєднане у нас Майже повністю
резерв сума якщо ще раз дуже не можу
відключити мікрофони зараз до наступного
року будь ласка колеги
я дуже прошу виключити мікрофони зайвими
для початкової школи Ми думаємо вже
тоді Ми продовжуємо Працюємо з секцією
захисту країни основи здоров'я
головного управління загальної середньої
та дошкільної освіти Міністерства освіти
і науки України
прошу Доброго дня всім учасникам нашої
конференції
дуже мені приємно вітати вас усіх в
цьому онлайн форматі хотілося б перш за
все
привітати вас з
майбутнім початком навчального року та
побажати усіх гараздів цей нелегкий для
нас
для нас особисто і для всієї країни час
так
як ви всі знаєте війна несла в корективи
в наше життя і особливо у життя
організації школи тобто організації
освітнього процесу багато стало викликів
перед українською освітою і зокрема саме
викликів щодо організації навчання з
різних формах як офлайн форматі в онлайн
форматі змішаному навчанні також
постало багато питань щодо
реалізації змісту навчальних програм
закладу загальної середньої освіти і так
як ви всі знаєте що після початку
збройної агресії було прийнято рішення
щодо оновлення змісту багатьох
навчальних предметів міністерством
це це оновлення стало відповіді на
виклики перш за все часу на виклики на
агресію яку здійснила Російська
Федерація і тому низка предметів тобто
зміст цих предметів зазнав істотних змін
і хотілося би теж за все розпочати з тих
змін які стосуються перш за все такого
світоглядного предмету важливого
предмету який вивчається у старшій школі
закладів загальної середньої освіти як
захист України
перш за все хочу сказати що була в
травні червні місяці працювала робоча
група яка
напрацювала ці зміни
хотілося б зазначити що це не є
кардинальні зміни але адже ви всі знаєте
що програма захисту України коли
змінилася назва з захисту вітчизни на
захист України зазнала істотних змін і
Була майже
перероблена досить досить суттєво тобто
зазначена за зазначеною програмою
заклади освіти України працювали лише
один рік так агресія внесла свої
корективи і ми
зробили також деякі істотні зміни в
певні розділи розширили перш за все
частину тих
практичних знань і навичок які мають
бути засвоєними здобувачами
старшій школі тобто зробили деякі
акценти де
в яких моментах внесли
точкові зміни у
реалізацію змісту освіти саме в перш за
все вступній частині визначились перш за
все з тими світоглядами речами які були
спричинені саме агресією ставлення до
агресора з тими подіями які зараз
відбуваються саме
елементами які перш за все стосуються
гібридної війни гібридних процесів і цих
викликів які не є суто військовими Також
ми намагалися звернути на це увагу в
змісті програми захисту України перш за
все Хочу зазначити що змін зазнало дві
програми ви всі знаєте що в нас програма
рівня стандарту - це
для всіх закладів
розуміти в тому числі
професійно-технічних і закладів фахової
передвищої освіти окрім
загальної середньої освіти а також
програма для закладів спеціалізованої
освіти військового профілю
профільна програма з предмета захисту
України також хотілося б зазначити що
предмет захист України рівня стандарту
вивчається за двома типовими за двома
навчальними планами Тобто ви всі знаєте
що в нас цей предмет ділиться на групи
тобто окремо вивчають дівчата це захист
України він називається з уточненням
основи медичних знань а також для
хлопців і обидві ці програми цих
програми тобто типові навчальні плани
типові плани зазнали змін
перш за все було внесено зміни щодо
розширення знань з основ цивільного
захисту а саме тут колеги
більш звернуть вашу увагу на це це
основи цивільного захисту в питаннях
поводження з вибухонебезпечними
предметами ви всі знаємо що після
госпітальної агресії після будь-якої
війни Україна
забруднюється цими предметами і ми
будемо
стикатися з цими проблемами впродовж
багатьох років після завершення цієї
збройної агресії тому Саме навчання
учнів закладів загальної середньої
освіти та професійної освіти та фахової
передвищої освіти передбачає саме
визначення цих компетенцій які дозволять
правильно поводитися з цими предметами і
перш за все реагувати на надзвичайній
ситуації які спричинена перш за все
військовими діями також хотілося б
зазначити що внесено також зміни у
світогляду частину висвітлення
українського
[музика]
російсько-української війни яка як ми
всі знаємо ми почалася 24 лютого це і
гаряча фаза розпочалася 24 лютого цього
року а розпочалася ще в 14-му році і з
різними аспектами цієї війни також учні
на уроці захист України мають бути
ознайомлені
уточненого аспекти щодо гібридної війни
тобто поняття гібридна війна введено ще
було з нами в 15-му році в програму
також Воно більш уточнено і розширили
велику увагу приділено Також я розумію
що
кібербезпеці і
поводженням з інформацією Тобто це і
вивчення на уроці окремих питань і
медіаграмотності кібербезпеки поводження
в віртуальному просторі адже ми всі
бачимо що війна не обмежується полем бою
а також існує і віртуальному просторі в
інтернеті ведеться і Тому перш за все
учні закладів освіти мають бути
готовими до протистояння цієї агресії
саме віртуальному просторі тому я би
хотів перш за все всім учасникам
у нашої наради побажати успіхів якщо
якісь будуть Запитання Ви можете їх
писати в чаті і ми будемо на них
відповідати і я думаю учасники
які
спікер які будуть в подальшому виступати
слідом за мною будуть Детально
розповідати про ці зміни які ми внесли у
програму захист України Хочу зазначити
що перш за все це чулочкові зміни
підручник захист вітчизни які були
розроблені також є чинними лише
змінилася назва предмету Я ще раз кажу
ще рік тому і відповідно
учителі закладів освіти можуть працювати
за цими підручниками але ж як кажуть
світ не стоїть на місці І потрібно
завжди оновлювати інформацію що
зазначено відповідних методичних
рекомендаціях які буде
невдовзі випущені міністерством для
організації викладання і продовження
освітнього процесу з предмету захисту
України Дякую всім за увагу всім успіхів
і слава Україні Дякую
Героям слава
Дякуємо пане Романове переходимо до
спікерів а саме до членів робочої групи
які саме модернізували оновлювали
[музика]
начальним програми з предмету захисту
України і ми просимо до слова Віктора
Поліщука учителя предмета захисту країни
нововолинського ліцею №8 Нововолинської
міської ради Волинської області які би
відповідальним секретарем-модератором
робочої групи
навчальної програми захист України а на
віктори просимо вас до слова ми знаємо
що ми з нами так я з вами поняла
запрошення і Степанович включіть звук не
чутно вас чомусь Правильно Тут стоїть
Да це є спеціальностей запрошення от е-е
встановлювати
сь попрошую як на початку
11-й годині в вимкніть будь ласка
учителі дотичні до захисту
захистимо нашу інформацію Слава Україні
Шановні колеги
мені випала честь присутніми тут людьми
зараз просто всіх не переглядаю пані
Євгенія Вітаю вас та пане Романе
долучитися до зміни навчального предмета
програма навчального предмета яке диктує
життя не це небажання це не
умовно хотелке знаєте коли вносиш в
програму
бажано
виживальницький запас і щоб на випуску
наш випускник оцей 16-17 літній умів і
знав як це зробити то Вибачте це
продиктоване життя і коли кажуть що
потрібно вміти орієнтуватися не тільки
гаджетом адже можеш просидіти в підвалі
два тижні без жодного струму
і потім ти повинен знайти де цей Північ
і де це була ця Стежина на заході щоб
вийти з цього села чи з цього дачного
кооперативу щоб просто вийти бо ти хочеш
бути живим
то ці зміни в дану програму виносилася
саме життям саме життям яке розставляє
акценти саме ставить оцінки
і вибачте предмет захисту країни не
передбачає так він передбачає і критерії
оцінювання і 12 бальну систему але він
має одну єдину оцінку життя
і якщо з цього предмету наш випускник
наш 17-літній що покидає заклад
загальної середньої освіти буде мати
іншу оцінку
зміни в програмі всі оцінувши всі оці
стандарти нічого не варті
і якщо наш випускник не залишиться живим
Шановні колеги я готовий показати
порівняльну табличку що ми передбачали
якщо дозволить Мені зараз так Отже
порівняльна табличка на
якщо я сподіваюсь це помітно
В мене чорний екран
чорний екран дивно повинен бути жодного
все є на екрані слухати Так дякую Дякую
ми спробували змінити певні частинки як
пояснювальній записці адже тут десь щось
якось туди-сюди ми добавляли якісь певні
моменти щоб посили той чи інший абзац
хто чи інше речення сподіваюсь учителі
які отримують До речі тільки що в чаті
встиг прочитати коли ж буде затверджена
програма затверджена програма уже
затверджена і уже на сайті Міністерства
освіти та також на моєму персональному
блозі учителя Віктор Поліщук учитель
дуже легко знайти програма вже є від
3.08.22 року
що ми змінювали ще
конкретно розділ статути збройних сил
України надзвичайно нудний надзвичайно
найцікавий але Повірте потрібний ми
перевели з розділу і зробили окремою
темою
окремою далі
ми
додаємо
будь ласка
виключіть мікрофони будь ласка Я і так
досить голосно говорю і сподіваюсь мене
з Волинської області чути аж в Київ Ну
поки що так не получається жартую але
основні засади
кібербезпеки ось тут вони і проявляються
коли ми вміємо користуватись приладом
коли ми не вміємо користуватись приладом
коли ми приладом користуємось
недосконало наш предмет наш предмет
повинен ідеально навчити користуватися
приладами будь-яким
і прочитати інструкцію практично
будь-якою мовою
хіба лише не ієрогліфами китайськими але
Повірте і ними також
сьогодні у війська поступає озброєння як
з Чехії так і з Польщі так і з Німеччини
і з Іспанії і зі сполучених із Канади на
усіх мовах і вибачте стоп старт
приблизно однаково але є вверх-вниз
додолу чи даун
ми це повинні прочитати і наш випускник
Це повинен прочитати
як і попросивши вас вимкнути мікрофони
будь ласка також Отже Дана тема відсутня
основні засади
кібербезпеки так цього ще немає в
підручниках тому будемо користуватися
усілякими джерелами але прошу дуже
шукаючи джерела шукати їх в надійних
інтернет-медіа джерелах там де це дійсно
реальна це а не це буде якийсь там
за вірусований чи російський Не дай Бог
над ресурс ви знаєте все-таки що вони
значно потужніше сиділи в інтернет чим
ну Україна величезна кількість
програмного а зокрема Піратського
забезпечення все-таки з приставкою Room
Так ось тут от в цій середньому
стовпчику якщо це і детальніше розписана
Так ми змінюємо певні
компетентності у природничих науках і
технологіях це я про це пробував
трішечки зачепитися з самого
початку також те що відсутнє відсутнє
відсутня відсутня додає додаємо учень
учениця зуміє здатна матиме уявлення
по цьому всьому
зробити шановні Ми даємо
як відновлюватись після певної втоми
цього ми не розглядали навіть на 20-й
рік
після
важких певних вправ з навантаженням
біглів занять тактичної підготовки із
стройової підготовки в тому числі Ми
повинні дати хоча б поняття як наш
випускник наш юнак буде відновлюватись
тобто вправи на відновлення після
перевантаження реабілітації і так далі в
цього не було Це буде І будем навчатися
ми з вами колеги
відсутнє знає прийоми правила і так далі
формує вміє визначати це те що у нас в
вогневій хоча б двома трьома способами
не тільки буде сподіватися на дальномір
сучасні прилади вони можуть зламатися
вони можуть перестати мати джерело
струму сі буде
акумуляторний тому подібний і перестати
вимірювати Ми повинні все-таки вміти
далі шановні ми частково змінюємо основи
військової топографії перечитайте
порівняйте в розділ основи цивільного
захисту додається зверніть увагу
чотири в лівому стовпчику чотири в
середньому те що стало 5 додається тема
Основи запобігання і реагування на
зазвичай
Перепрошую
попередження четверте попередження
ризиків від вибуху небезпечних предметів
від вибухонебезпечних предметів це
допомагали нам асоціація саперів України
і кажуть що вони розпочнуть цю
підготовку з предмету основи здоров'я з
молодших ніж десяті класи 8-9 класи
сподіваюсь Сьогодні ми почуємо як що
вони
передбачають і тут розписано детальніше
як це і є
знову ж таки і
основи запобігання реагування на
надзвичайні ситуації також змінюємо адже
обстріли
розрушення цивільних будівель
критичної інфраструктури
водозабезпечення електрозабезпечення
просто
переміщення в умовах населеного пункту
показала що нам треба більш детальніше
вивчати ці теми ці підходити до вивчення
цього матеріалу Шановні колеги
опрацьовуємо значно детальніше і
опрацьовуємо з
колегами в школі з класними керівниками
старших середніх класів і на днях
цивільного захисту і перестаємо
проводити День цивільного захисту хоча
би один раз в рік бажано для мене хоча
би раз чверть що два місяці або і навіть
частіше
чоловіче на рік не раз в семестр
це тема немає попередження ризиків буде
ця тема ризиків від вибухонебезпечних
предметів і більш детально розписано як
це все робиться до речі зараз
на розгляді в інституті модернізації
змісту освіти
навчально-методичний посібник з даного
напрямку сподіваюсь він скоро буде
рекомендований І він потрапить в заклади
освіти так щоб він став
конкретним джерелом допомоги учителям
керівникам класним керівникам усім
зацікавленим яке яке хотіли проводити
подібне навчання якісно на належному
рівні
з змінюємо частково і в тактично
підготовку призначення тактико-технічні
характеристики та порядок використання
засобів аерозольного маскування
димові гранати димові шашки
евакуація поранення під прикриттям цих
димових завіс і тому подібне цього немає
Шановні колеги
завантажуємо програму розглядаємо
переглядаєм і бачимо що ми змінюємо і
додаємо як і в тактичну медицину от до
медичну допомогу як в тематичний план
номер один так і в тематичний план номер
два також тематичний план №2 вивчення
предмета захисту України дівчатами також
підлягає зміни в розділі основи
цивільного захисту і удосконалення в
тактичній медицині власне по змінам
програми У мене все і я
готовий вислухати
якщо є якісь запитання чи надати слово
колезі Євгенії Юріївні алексейчук
натував це як буде
план вашої наступних роботи тому що люди
тут пишуть про методичні рекомендації
для
дистанційної освіти по захисту України
Ну дійсно з вашим предметом дистанційне
тут є певні особливості є питання
є звичайно певні особливості досить
складно досить важко Звичайно
що хочу сказати що для цього є інтернет
джерела
ну раджу про що
розглянути ось цей
копіюю і викладаю в чат
персональний блог учителя
Віктора Поліщука Віктор Поляков
Захистимо Україну якщо хтось саме може
знайти просто Віктор Поліщук учитель тут
я уже відповідаю чи можна скинути ссилку
на програму там вона є це саме верхнє
повідомлення на цьому блозі на цьому
блозі також можна знайти
електронний збірник дидактичних Ігор які
легко граються на телефоні Тобто ви тут
юнаки поскладають там позбирають
розбирають автомат поскладають військові
звання дівчата по накладають турнікети
повідповідають на ті чи інші запитання
по порядковості наданню Так це не заміна
але це хоть частково хоть трішечки це
таких методичних рекомендації також
підготовлені і якщо було сказано
сьогодні до кінця тижня вони будуть там
також
ряд інтернет-джерел не тільки мій
персональний блок а персональні блоги
учителів і учителів які сьогодні навіть
В окопах Сергія савенка але він
продовжує правити свій блог Ну він так
коли я його звернувся до нього він так
акуратненько сказав що він під лисиком
Я зрозумів де
змінюйте А ми змінюємо історію щоб
більше ніхто не мав права змінити
географію оце учитель захисту України і
його персональний Інтернет вже ресурс
також буде зазначений методичних
рекомендаціях Шановні колеги
також Я впевнений що
ряд групи в соціальній мережі Facebook
та сама захист України шкільний предмет
яку я також модерую
видає багато відповідей на ці питання
які зустрічаються сьогодні в чаті
готові поділитися мікрофоном з Євгенією
Олексійчук як також на сьогоднішній
зустрічі Повірте
здатна багато що сказати і
в аналогічній формі як у мене
Віктор дуже цікаво чесно скажу я слухала
вас в захватом далі І ми пропонуємо
слово Євгеній Олексійчук вчитель
предмета захисту України Гімназії
№34 липить імені Віктора максименка
Подільського району міста Києва пані
Євгенія Ми хочемо вас побачити і почути
рада вітати всіх учасників а тут як
скачати дуже дуже
розповідь моєму колезі а в принципі
настільки змістовно що не дуже є багато
Що додати але все ж таки я спробую перше
на що я хочу звернути увагу мабуть про
це потрібно обов'язково сказати дай
трошечки вже пане Роман на це голосив це
вивчення тематичного предмету
відбувається за тематичним планом один і
тематичним планом 2
наголошую предмет називається захист
України і в дівчат з основи
медичних знань уточнення І зараз я чую
багато від колег що
намагаючись десь трошечки зекономити
бюджетні кошти відбуваються поєднання
цих двох груп ще раз
наголошую що у нас незалежно від
кількості учнів в класі йдеться за двома
математичними планами друге що ми також
змінили
суттєво це раніше було що в залежності
від матеріального технічного бази
закладу кількість годин саме програмного
матеріалу могло бути скореговане в межах
одного розділу 20%. так тепер ми даємо
більше
такої Свободи
вчителю і він може взагалі зторгувати
також 20%, але вже не в межах всього
розділу а всієї програми так коригувати
в залежності від
бази можливості і так далі
ще хочу звернути увагу що у нас такий
суттєвий відбулася
суттєві зміни це
стосується теми підготовка до
Національного спро в Україні ви всі
знаєте Мабуть що у нас є закон про
основи національного супроводу і Саме
тут ми хотіли звернути на нього увагу і
наголосити що діти мають
розумітися на цьому та знати
правові організаційні засади
національного супроводу його основи
підготовки ведення і так далі також
Звертаю увагу на ще один момент - це
досить суттєво змінилася тактична
підготовка з чого ми виходили якраз з
того що Наша задача - це
підготовити майбутніх і захисників до
захисту України
тому тут якраз ми додали індивідуальні
дії
сьогодні індивідуальні дії у нас були
переміщення але вони трошечки ми
вдосконалили але крім цього
інженерні споруди їх використання як їх
облаштовувати далі знову ж таки вузли
зв'язки
багаття як які способи приготування та
добування їжі військовослужбовцями
раціон військовослужбовців знову ж таки
гостру питання стає
водозабезпечення да під час
виконання бойових завдань яка добова
норма води як порядок її використання
природні джерела і як їх можна очистити
да пошук джерел водопостачання Ми всі
знаємо що ця інформація важлива навіть
не тільки для військовослужбовців А для
будь-якої людини
яка навіть не
складається до збройних сил України або
за станом здоров'я не може але це ті
знання які дозволяють вижити
ще особливість
трошки ми вже вказали про те що додали
невелику кількість необхідність знати
вправи на розвантаження на коли ми
поносимо
той самий бронежилет
добу 2 не всі знають як можна
розвантажити ці м'язи ну і ще один
аспект - це психологічні вправи які
дозволяють як військовослужбовців так і
просто будь-який людині
справитись з панікою страхом тому що ну
страх навіть на війні це нормально І
якщо людина не боїться то Вважайте що
він вже помре Це де говорять наші
військовослу цьому році які захищають
Тому це нормально Але маємо дати хоча
або основні моменти як справитися з цими
проявами страху Ну в принципі це основні
такі моменти і передам Слово також нашим
колегам які долучалися стосовно мінної
безпеки вони більш детально розкажуть що
змінилося в цьому
напрямку якщо є питання задавайте
Можна питання Доброго дня Надія
колозкова фаховий коледж університет
таке питання Скажіть будь ласка тож на
цій зустрічі у нас 500 человек не у всіх
на жаль була можливість долучитися чи
буде десь на сайті мон
или на вашому сайті розміщена ця зустріч
у запису
можна я скажу
Шановні колеги весь запис всіх
конференцій тобто секцій буде розміщено
на офіційному сайті мов тобто на YouTube
каналі
тому хто не долучився може потім
передивитися цю трансляцію зараз
трансляція в онлайні відбувається як на
ресурсі на Ютубі так і на
Зумі Тому все це
можуть просто зараз підключитися до зуму
або тобто до YouTube щоб подивитися і
задати відповідну запитання
дякую
я хотілось би додати І побажати колегам
[музика]
що програма в принципі дуже непогана
хороша але ми бачимо що
іноді виникають проблеми з її
викладанням тому що ми стикалися з тим
що діти наприклад не знають що таке
турнікет як зупинити корову те що як
надати допомогу хоча це все є в програмі
ті самі
стандартні протоколи базова підтримка
життя зупинка кровотечі протокол ttc
надання в бойових умовах ми бачимо що
діти не чули навіть про це і Це вже
говорить про нашу фаховість Колеги
давайте розвиватися і давати максимально
для того щоб наші діти були готові до
будь-яких викликів цієї війни дякую
якщо можна запитання Скажіть будь ласка
кількість годин непередбачених не
Передбачається збільшити зв'язку з
змінами
Шановні колеги щодо кількості годин Ну
це вже тема заїжджена ще певно з 90-х
років ви Самі знаєте в 15-му році
кількість годин з однієї було збільшено
до півтори у
вивчення програми двох годин зменшено до
1,5 року
освіти в яких викладається предмет
захист України мінімум має півтори
години на тиждень бути це в першому
семестрі два рази на тиждень або навпаки
а в другому один раз на тих або навпаки
Якщо ж заклади освіти мають таку
можливість наприклад Тернопільська
область вся і місто Тернопіль можливість
варіативної частини виділити півгодини і
розширити вивчення предмету на дві
години це приймає зараз відповідно до
закону Про
освіту про повну загальну середню освіту
закладу осві він виділяється півгодини і
вчитель працює дві години в закладі
освіти тобто формує свою освітню
програму і працює за цим предметом 2
години на тиждень це рівень стандарту Я
вже говорю що в нас ще є профільний
рівень d5 годинників є заклади освіти
спеціалізовані ви всі знаєте є
в закладах освіти спеціалізовані класи
військового профілю там 5 годин на
тиждень Ну це вже залежить від закладу
освіти і від його засновника якщо вони
засновують такий профіль хоча в нас
зараз ви всі бачите війна і потреба в
професійні підготовці профільні
підготовці майбутніх військових і
майбутніх працівників сектору оборони
досить велика тому перспектива
військового з профілю в закладах
загальної середньої освіти є також
важливо але я думаю що коли буде
завершена реформа нової української
школи ми будемо працювати над профільною
стандартом профільної школи саме це ми
досить добре врахуємо тому що там три
роки вивчення на профільну школу і
відповідно стандарти профіль буде
враховано і захист України в якому він
виглядає тобто початкова військова
підготовка і допризовна підготовка буде
представлена в цьому стандарті дякую
пана Романа є ще одне питання якщо немає
вчителя захисту України по програмі для
хлопців Ми сьогодні говоримо це ми
говоримо про основи здоров'я і я надаю
слово Володимиру Пономаренко голову
правління всеукраїнської громадської
організації
всеукраїнська спілка вчителів і тренерів
і членів робочої групи зановлення даної
навчальної програми пане Володимире
просимо вас до слова я знаю що О точно з
нами
слухаємо вас
але не чуємо Володимир Степанович
тепер мабуть тепер чуємо просимо будь
ласка Я вас час писав прохання до
учасників Вимкнути мікрофон і сам так
вимкнути якщо включити
Добренько пока слайм
і сподіваюсь що і презентацію ми його
видно
»
[музика]
педагоги є пропендика або додаткова
підготовка дітей до такої
фундаментальної підготовки вже дорослих
Ну можна вважати
юнаків і дівчат але теж з користю і
практичним новим от склад робочої групи
наш складався з 5-7 осіб вибачте
і він наведений до тут теж були як
кажуть
Бригада в тому числі і Сергій чуткий
представляв якраз цей колектив який в
тому числі були попередня
коротко про предмет основи здоров'я цей
предмет є базовим у 6-9 класах але
базове з питань здоров'я і безпеки
зрозуміло що безпека надзвичайна так
кажуть актуальна зараз
цей предмет розрахований 35 годин на рік
з яких 4 години рази і саме ці новації
які пропонуються додаткові теми вони в
основному використовуються пропонуються
використовувати за рахунок цих 4 годин
навчальна програма для кожного класу
мається на увазі шостий восьмий шостий
сьомий восьмий дев'ятий має 4 Розділи з
однаковою назвою перше - це безпека і
здоров'я людини друге фізична складова
здоров'я третій психічний духовна
складова і четвертий соціальний і саме
ключові зміни вносяться перший розділ що
стосується фундаментальних і практичних
навичок здоров'я і безпеки і здоров'я
починаючи з цього з
2022-23 навчального року предмет основи
здоров'я поступово змінюється
інтегрований курс здоров'я безпека і
добробут і я думаю що одне з ключових
завдань наших всіх авторів модельних
програм внести відповідні зміни які
будуть опрацьовані в цьому навчальному
році в предмети основи здоров'я і
захисту Вітчизни
концепція змій з чого ми виходили коли
разом прідно з усіма членами робочої
групи і не тільки бо приймали участь
дистанційно і методисти з основ здоров'я
не всі але багато людей то
[музика]
було узгоджено концепцію змін тобто до
навчання програми внесено
до них ще трошки які пропонуються
вивчати за рахунок самого цих чотирьох
резервних годин програма і так насичена
далі додаткові теми рекоменду навчати на
початку навчального року особливо зараз
це актуально Коли ми перший раз в умовах
війни
Дітлахи чи дистанційно чи очно У деяких
областях будуть навчатися у школі
додаткова Тематика до кожного класу
внесена переважно до першого розділу але
деяка додаткова інформація міститься і в
інших роз
ладах дотична Ну наприклад це питання
які будуть стосуватися психологічної
підготовки
теми які Додано до програми
їх 8 всього таких як то кажуть
[музика]
загальних це захисні дії під час
повітряної тривоги авіанальоту обстрілу
укриття
видимосховища підвали принцип дві стіни
тощо маршрут евакуації від школи додому
до боку сховища умова йде про дітей 6-9
класу безпека поводження з виходу
вибухонебезпечними та незнайомими
предметами мінами снарядами тощо
виживання в екстремальних надзвичайних
ситуаціях розшифровується під завалом
під час відсутності води електрики
каналізації тощо це те що ми на
превеликий жертв спостерігаємо у нашому
житті Сьогодні у багатьох областях як
поводитися з збройними людьми особливо
ну зокрема моя термінологія з окупантами
Да бо вони містять надзвичайно багато
небезпек і ті люди які були під
окупацією тимчасово які продовжують
знають все це всі особливі небезпеки як
треба поводитися так щоб не спати
відразу жертвою то кажуть терору
невідкладна до медична допомога зокрема
опіки кровотеча травми і психологічна
допомога про самодопомогу йде стрес
не
професійно-психологічну роботу Там дуже
багато є на сайті інституту модернізації
змісту освіти рекомендації розробок а
саме те що може людина або учень або
Дитина робити сама з собою кодування
стресу страху тривогу
приклад внесених змін програм тільки
фрагмент знов таки пам'ятаємо що
основний зміни відносяться розділ 1
безпеки здоров'я наприклад ризики
воєнного часу есть там така загальна
тематика ризики ризики в зоні бойових
дій на окупованих звільнених територіях
екологічні проблеми технології які
виникли внаслідок воєнних дій контакти з
озброєними людьми захист під час
обстрілів
повітряна тривога сигналу ще треба знати
саме допомога і так далі тут тематику як
на попередньому слайді вона відповідно
до віку відповідно до
рівня підготовленості учнів
і де розміщено оновлену програму
оновлена які Міністерство освіти можна
сканувати цей код і перейти відразу а
можна перейти до
щ і завершуючи уже свій виступ Я хочу
сказати що
розуміємо що надзвичайно важливо стає
питання про навчально-методичне
забезпечення ми коли працювали у робочій
групі деякі
надали вже але такі як то кажуть проекти
матеріалів
наприклад Сергей чутки надав розробки
уроку Я не знаю якщо буде доцільно то
можливо їх розмістити ще
на сайті інститутом модернізації змісту
освіти як такий попередній матеріал не
знаю Я думаю що пан Сергійчук надасть
світу Дякую за увагу
Дякую Володимир
розмову Про навчальні матеріали якщо це
розробки уроків то розробки уроків
грифування експертизи не вимагають їх
можна використовувати якщо вчителі
нададуть Ну у нас на сайті ми розмістити
На жаль таке не зможемо але якщо якісь
будуть у вас сторінки фейсбуках чи що от
як пане Віктор Поліщук показував блоги
можна там розмістити А вся іншим
література Що стосується грипування
подавайте будемо графувати і оповідання
було ще Володимир Степанович хвилиночку
по захисту України Я думаю що тут так
само за якими підручниками будуть
викладатися дані навчальні предмети
оскільки програми мають зміни Ну давайте
дивитися реально на ситуацію надрукувати
нові підручники ми ніяк не встигнемо Ані
на 1 вересня А ні на наступний у нас
питання досі стоїть ви чули на початку
про підручники п'ятого класу які є дуже
гарно вигідними А що стосується
підручників чинних шостого по 11-й клас
це і Ці предмети і всі інші дає зміни ми
звернемося до видавництва авторів щоб
вони поможливості доопрацювали ці
підручники відповідно нових
недозмін які внесені в навчальні
програми для того щоб можна було їх
замінити в електронній бібліотеці нашого
інституту але це знову робота яка
потребує певного часу щоб її можна було
здійснити тому ми як тільки будуть
оновлені варіанти будемо розміщувати в
наш електронні бібліотеці Дякуємо і я
хочу передати слово Ігорю гризніченко
експертом з безпеки асоціації саперів
України його виступ він буде стосуватися
двох наших предметів які ми все в секції
розглядаємо і захисту України основ
здоров'я тому що якщо ми уважно слухали
попередніх трьох доповідачів Кожен з них
говорив про вибухонебезпечні речовини
предмети які зараз ці теми більш
поглиблено будуть розглядатися програмі
захисту України і більше збільшена
кількість годин і тематики в основах
здоров'я тому матеріали дуже цікаві і
пан Ігор дасть інформацію де може бути з
ними познайомитися пана Ігорю будь ласка
просимо вас до слова
так Добрий день чути Мене видно що ти но
не видно а не видно але от тепер бачимо
Дякуємо і написано Ірина шуженко
запустила демонстрацію екрану я прошу
вже чорний екран і ще немає інформації О
зараз вже мені дали доступ зараз я
закину є з'явилася
слухати вас і дивитись презентацію і
видно мене так видно чути прекрасно все
чудово Дякую Так я представлюсяченка а
відомий також Як Ігор молодан Я в чаті
записав свій скажемо контактну пошту це
для того щоб може комусь буде цікаве
більш детально познайомитись саме з тими
на роботу Ну наработками які в мене є а
є Ось і по міной безпеці є і по
загальній безпеці потім в повітряній
тривоги там і по-іншому також декілька у
мене книг вже виданих тобто по виживанню
в екстремальних умовах я і військових 20
років виживанням займаюсь 20 років
експерт з безпеки асоціації саперів
України ну тобто є певний е-е досвід в
цьому питанні і прошу якщо якісь будуть
у когось питання Ігор молодан я на
Фейсбуці можна мене знайти і також ось
по тій самій електронної пошті що я
залишив у чаті і почну щоб уже далеко не
ходити з навчання попередження ризиків
пов'язаних з вибухонебезпечними
предметами
Так зараз на весь екран
так так так так так так так так так
як воно не можу розкрити на весь екран
попробую переключити як Чого воно не
переключається
зараз якось треба скрутити верхню Я
вибачаюсь але у мене
не переключається
[музика]
ікра пане Ігорю все нормально
так Тобто це буде ось таке невеличке ми
взагалі-то проводимо десь годину ця
інформування я потрачу вашої уваги
буквально 10 хвилин основні такі тези
будуть ну тобто перше ми починаємо це
для те щоб можна було саме інформувати
дітей щодо небезпеки тобто починаємо з
трьох золотих правил це не чіпай не
Підходь повідомл службу порятунку і за
номером 101 і звичайно що всі ці питання
вже піднімаються по кожному слайду це те
що стосується загальної проблематики
тобто наразі вже у нас забруднена 160
000 це ще застаріла інформація 132 160
тисяч квадратних кілометрів це найбільша
така забруднена територія мабуть у світі
і ми вже займаємо другу сходинку у світі
по інцидентам пов'язаним зараз
вибухонебезпечного предметами тобто і
покараннями по загибелі від цих
предметів тобто за після Афганістану ми
на другий сходинки у світі звичайно щоб
ми європейська держава європейська
країна в центрі Європи саме відбувається
ось таке жахіття і це дуже велика
проблема бо один рік війни - це вісім
років розмінування тому можна порахувати
дев'ятий рік у нас війна і звичайно що
це буде 10 липня тривати саме
розмінування і починаємо з
ідентифікації загроз тобто протипіхотні
зміниться одна з таких
великих загроз саме на територіях де
ведуться активні бойові дії або на
деокупованих територій і багато зараз є
інцидентів де саме і діти взагалі-то
діти мабуть більше ще частина зараз
потрапляє Ось на ці растяжки потрапляє
на протипіхотні зміни бачимо декілька
видів це вже сучасні протипіхотні міни я
не буду впадати в деталі але сучасні
протипіхотні міни дуже
у них дуже
вже
сучасна технологія Ось вони
дистанційного обмінування видно в відео
зараз пішло
так якщо він видно то це вже сучасні так
так Це вже видно Дякую бачите самі це
пом-2 які дистанційно закидуються або з
Дронів можуть закидуватися або касетними
навіть з гранатомету самі стають на
ножки Уже все в бойові стан самі
випускають Ось такі датчики тобто зараз
теж побачимо імітація того що ця Міна це
сучасна російська Міна у нас такий міни
нема на озброєнні і зараз вони активно
теж використовується на сході ну
побачите сама сама стала сама
розкидувала такі датчики цілі тобто вони
9,5 м Кожний з них 4 датчика в різні
кути ну тобто вже 19 м - це радіус саме
небезпеки тобто підходе людина
чіпляється і вибухає підривається тобто
треба бути Звичайно що уважним обережним
з такими мінами тобто є міни які
вкопуються в землю які становляться я
міни які людей будуть бачимо посередині
підстрибуюча Міна і взагалі-то зліва теж
підстрибуюча Міна сенсорна Міна Тобто
вона підстрибує до 1 м і навкруги на
360° все вражає там в радіусі
Точніше на дистанції до 20-ти метрів
наступна загроза - це
протитранспортні міни тобто міни які
встановлюються проти транспорту та Але
звичайно що вони і е-е мають загрозу
бути і для людей Чому Тому що вони
можуть бути Не в стійкому стані ми не
знаємо як вони використовували точніше
зберігалися це ще радянського
виробництва на відміну від цих по
діагоналі дві зміни які вже сучасні це
російська виробництва міни і звичайно що
такі міни вони
дистанційно навіть оце справа в
Верховному углу це дистанційно
обмінування яка вже була застосована під
час під час нашої війни і на сході у
Харкові розкидувалась в районах такі
протитранспортні міни якщо ми бачимо
десь подібне як і попереднє дистанційна
Міна ось метелик Так звана так і така
Міна е-е продовгувати якщо ми бачимо
щось подібне одну то навкруги їх будуть
десятки десятки може бути і сотні Тому
треба бути Звичайно що обережним Ну і
найбільша загроза зараз це боєприпаси що
вони вибухнули ну тобто їх взагалі по
статистиці третина третина боєприпасів
вона не спрацьовує мається на увазі
радянського виробництва це ті самі
боєприпаси які використовуються зараз
які були на складах там де тривалого
зберігання і зараз використовують проти
Е проти нас і звичайно що третина - це
дуже велика кількість бо якщо взяти у
середньому 10 000 випущених снарядів або
у нас і по 20 тисяч не надо буде по 50
000 на добу то можна підрахувати скільки
саме їх не вибухає це дуже велика
проблема Ну по-перше бо вони не останній
і знаходяться в бойовому стані тобто
вони за певних умов не вибухнули навіть
Були серед спеціалістів середрів вже не
один випадок підриву саме на таких ось
запалень якби боєприпасах якщо вони
вибухнули а саме Ну тому що десь щось не
розібрались якісь міри безпеки було
нарушено але якщо підривається навіть
саперри то звичайно що звичайним людям
навіть підходити туди і цікавитись
фотографуватись з ними не можна Я вже
мовчу просто там збирати зберігати
переносити дарувати і там або десь на
металобрухт здавати тобто не можна до
них навіть е-е Ну підходити бо вони
можуть за певних умов здетонувати
детонатори Підривники вам їх можна
знайти на позиціях які покинути так як і
ось Залишені боєприпаси але зауважу саме
на детонаторах підривниках бо вони такі
не схожі на вибухові речовини і навіть
теж підкреслю як військовий що нас є
військові багато військові дуже великий
процент який навіть Ну їх в руках не
тримали не знають як з ними поводитись і
тому теж можуть і кольцо були такі
випадки і там десь хтось
Ну десь нарушає якісь порядок роботи цих
Але там є Детонатор там є певний капсуль
який спрацьовує спрацьовує рідина яка
займається ну тобто Вона може Звичайно
що відірвати скажемо якщо є кінцівку то
фалангу точно і зробити інвалідів Ну
просто із-за того що людина цікавиться і
це саме стосується і дітей бо це дуже
велика проблема діти не розуміють що це
небезпека їм треба це на це На цьому
зауважувати і боєприпаси Залишені
небезпечні саме їх дуже велика кількість
і коли працював і під час своєї місії у
в Африці в Західній Африці під час
Другої своєї війни у АТО під час зараз
вже е-е надо окупованих територіях хто
підкреслює що таких дуже велика
кількість знахідок тобто покинутих на
позиціях паркинутих боєприпасів ці всі
боєприпаси небезпечно Ну перше за все те
що їх можна їх мінутують їх можна
замінувати за одну хвилину там поставити
розтяжку Закрити цю кришечкою хто
відкриває там цікавиться що саме
знаходиться у цих ящиках то вже взлітає
разом зі всім боєкомплектом тому
Звичайно що теж на позиціях робити
Нічого І такі ящики цікавитись не можна
найбільша кількість випадків тренування
Як це не парадоксально це від набоїв і
зауважує саме викладацький склад Я
працював інформував і о-о-о
так але повторюсь я інформував і дітей і
вам як експеримент можу запропонувати у
своїх класах провести таке опитування У
кого є набої вдома і ось у кожному класі
одна-дві дитини піднімала руки і казала
мені дядька мені брат мені батько мені
ще хтось привозив ось з війни такий
сувенір і ось завдяки таким сувенірам
саме і є найбільша кількість випадків
травмування від вибухонебезпечних
предметів бо діти не знають що саме
робити з цими предмети з цими набоями я
сам був таким їх вівці я ріс у різних
гарнізонах і звичайно що вона полігонах
Ми теж шукали такі патрончики теж своїх
Звичайно у нас зброї нема але чим може
ще бавитись це кидати їх у багаті або
десь по капсулю блага що у нас не було
травмувань але якщо в моєму віці тоді
коли ми було 67-8 років розповідали саме
про небезпеку то я би напевно що ці не
займався такими речами Тому це треба
зауважувати треба зауважити і на тому що
є певна кримінальна відповідальність
якщо знаходяться такі предмети це вже до
7 років позбавлення волі Тобто це треба
зауважити дітям це треба наголошувати і
їх батькам І тим хто саме їм дарує такі
предмети бо відповідати буде не дитина а
саме той дорослий який їм подарував
звичайно дитина може відповідати тільки
своїм яким калістом якщо вона десь буде
його неправильно застосовувати
саморобні предмети тут все зрозуміло
якщо бачимо десь якісь предмети які
знаходяться у
містах загального користування то ми не
чіпаємо хтось залишив сумку не треба
туди заглядати І зараз я покажу зараз
покажу саме Чому Тому що все це може
бути заміновано все це може бути
саморобні вибухові пристрої ну Для
певних там мабуть є різні приклади Тобто
їх застосовують або для залякування або
туристичних
це все стосується цивільного населення
ось ми бачимо мінування реальні
мінування Це ось у картоплі знайшли десь
чи в ірпінічі в Бучі Це ось розтяжки
стоять в коробки з
цукерок в
іграшках дуже велика кількість заміну
бачимо і
мінуси побутова техніка Тобто я на Що
зауважу на те що по-перше найбільша
кількість мінувань це саме ручними
гранатами ручна граната є у кожного
бійця по 3-4-5 скільки хоче вони стільки
набирають цих ручних гранат тому Ніякого
нема тут зовсім
логіки ніякої нема послідовності де саме
вона буде використана як Міна Міна
розтяжка як Міна сюрприз як як Міна там
ловушка то Пасха точніше тому Звичайно
що вона буде окупованих територіях Це
велика проблема І звичайно що люди коли
Ми спілкувались на цих територіях я
тиждень їздив там спілкувався з людьми
працював разом з саперами то звичайно що
таких випадків дуже велика кількість
якщо ми бачимо ось внизу замінована
окладинка документа тобто такий ось шар
невеликий шар
пластиду там же тоненькі Детонатор
тоненькі батарейка все це є Але вміти
Звичайно що цим користуватися і мінуси
навіть документи тобто розуміємо що
Нічого І дітям взагалі кажемо нічого не
чіпаємо в зоні бойових дій нічого не
чіпаємо не свого нічого не чіпаємо не до
окупованих територіях поки це все не
буде перевірене і навіть на деокупованих
територіях своє до свого теж треба
уважно відноситись бо було багато
випадків і зараз люди ще повертаються і
стикаються з цими випадками мінування
саме
змінами пастками тобто саморобними або
навіть штатними мінами Ну і три вида ми
на вибухових травми тут Звичайно що від
фугасних від осколкових і від 3 травм
саме Від саморобних або тих те що я
казав детонатори тобто відриває фаланги
пальців Алло і ще й зауважу навіть по
набоям ще раз зауважу що був недавилось
три тижні тому випадок коли дорослий
чоловік захотів з патрона зробити собі
якісь брелок відкривачку є такі
відкривач відкривалки І почав його десь
там пиляти цей патрон на своєму станку
він підірвався відірвав йому фалангу
пальці потрапив у очі і теж зробив
інвалідам ну тобто це не те проблема не
тільки дітей а і дорослих так цим ми
займатися зараз не будемо перейдемо до
ознак небезпечних територій тобто якщо б
Як бачите цей зруйнований інфраструктура
це і міста обстрілів це і поля на яких
не ведеться господарча діяльність більше
Дари все це ті міста які потенційно
небезпечні які можуть бути потенційно
заміновані тобто зруйновані будівлі
покинути військова і цивільна техніка
теж мінуси були випадки мінування місця
пов'язані з військовою діяльністю і от
залишки та тварин які ось підірвалися на
за певних умов Тобто всі ці місця у нас
безпечна це тільки там де ми мешкаємо
якщо ми знаємо що тут безпечно це
асфальтові дороги це бетонні дороги це
такі прикриття де якщо хтось щось хоче
замінувати то його видно що там щось КП
щось видовбувалось в цьому асфальті щоб
туди поставити міну але в асфальт теж
міни е-е ставлять
так і по знакам по знакам У нас є
офіційний неофіційні тобто зауваження на
те що бачимо офіційні або неофіційні
знаки офіційний трикутник - чотирикутник
неофіційний це може бути будь-що що що
відбувається з певної
з певного ландшафту скажу на певній
території де велися або бойові дії тобто
або на деокупованих територіях це ми ще
працювали з 20-го року з цивільними на
Донеччині і Луганщині там таких випадків
дуже велика кількість коли знаходили
самі місцеві жителі позначали такими
позначками що тут небезпека потім
викликали за номером 101 Ну і звичайно
що це не розміновалася швидко це було
деякий час на розмінування щоб ну і
правила тобто правила модель правильної
поведінки Ми зупиняємося зупиняємося ні
в кого ні в якому разі ми не танцюємо не
переходимо не нагами там дмитриемся
зупиняємося на місці не панікуємо на
подивилися навкруги це якщо ми зустріли
вибухонебезпечний предмет не можна його
фотографувати не можна його помічати на
місці Тобто це все робити не можна
бо є за певних умов тож за зміни
магнітного поля є такі Детонатор який
спрацьовують ми знаємо що саме який
принцип роботи цього вибуху небезпечного
предмета Звичайно що він підривається і
може знищити людину тому ми відходимо
обережно у безпечне місце
200 м 300 Наскільки Ви вважаєте якщо це
пряма бачимось або десь за якісь брусли
за якісь перекриття якщо це близька є і
вже звідти ми можемо телефонувати Звідки
ми можемо фотографувати напрямок щоб
вказати потім геолокації для рятівників
і звідти ми телефонуємо саме 101 саме
101 не 102 не 103 не 104 саме 101 так же
як і у випадку якщо опинилися на мій на
мінному Полю ми не рухаємося і навіть не
відходимо вже тобто тут на мінному Полю
це робити заборонено бо якщо ми дійшли
до певної позиції побачили що це мінне
поле воно заміновано треба
знати що немає безпечного шляху змінного
поля в цьому випадку можна ризикнути
Зателефонувати якщо нікого поруч нема
або гукати чекати але стояти сидіти не
відриваючись свої кінцівки на тому місці
де ми вже замерли побачивши ці небезпеку
і потім вже чекати коли приїдуть сапери
І коли вже розмінують доступ покажуть
безпечний шлях і що стосується свідків
тобто якщо ми стали свідками інциденту
на мінному полі хтось підривався ні в
якому разі ми не біжимо є такі певні
алгоритми навіть швидке допомога не буде
йти до постраждалого поки не буде
перевірена ця діла ділянка були такі
приклади в мене є живі свідки в цьому
коли і дівчина підірвалася там е-е
чоловік її надав допомогу визвав швидку
швидка швидка приїхала Але з асфальтою
Дорогою не пішли у поґрунтовій бо
сказали тут може бути небезпечна ще
чита- чекали там 23 хв поки приїдуть
сапери перевірять і вже потім після
цього вже евакуювала дівчина залишилась
живою але щоб ви розуміли телефонуємо не
103 як чоловік в цьому випадку а 1001 і
вже після того можна продублювати на 103
тобто 101 оператор вже зрозуміє що саме
потрібно які саме потрібні
експерти в цьому випадку Ну і звичайно
що закінчуємо ми тест з цими трьома
правилами тобто і починаємо і закінчуємо
не чіпаємо не підходимо повідомляємо
службу порятунку якщо є питання готов
відповісти наприклад таке коротесеньке
вже я закінчив Дякую за увагу і якщо
треба буде моя допомога по розробці
певних матеріалів дуже багато на роботу
Я співпрацюю з міжнародними
організаціями по міжнародним стандартам
тобто щоб ви розуміли оце мідна безпека
того що є у вас назва Щас я вас покажу і
зауважу я бачив в програмі я б раджу
все-таки в програмі писати Саме навчання
з попередження ризиків від
вибухонебезпечних предметів Тобто це
найбільш таке є є є тобто по англійській
це
певна система по якою міжнародна
міжнародний стандарт ми його переклали
на наш на нашу мову і саме так воно
звучить тест стосується і загальної
безпеки тобто є cpp це Та ось безпека
загальна і школи і загально Що робити
під час раптових обстрілів під час
повітряної тривоги під час пожежі там
тобто є певні стандарти і в мене є змога
співпрацювати з тими людьми міжнародними
міжнародних регресів які дають мені саме
ці певні стандарти Я адаптую вже під
наші реалії Дякую за увагу
пане Ігорю Дякуємо дуже Я думаю що ви в
чаті залишите ваші контакти Ще раз бо
воно трошки там вже
приховалося пригубилася щоб люди могли
за необхідності до вас звернутися тут
просять поділитися презентацією ну
Дивіться це на ваш розсуд знову І у вас
є можливість
ну в департаменті освіти я там залишу
може залишити цю презентацію Це як і в
чаті так якось скопіювати
покликання на неї де ви її де ви люди
можуть зайти і скачати все зрозумів
думаю що дуже дякуємо ми закінчуємо нашу
секцію
секцію предметів захисту України і
основи здоров'я
[музика]
Ми закінчимо нас нашу секцію захисту
країни основ здоров'я ми будемо
передавати слово наступний секції тому
дуже великі прохання вчителів цих двох
предметів захист України основи здоров'я
вийти з
Зума надати можливість під'єднатися
бажаючи послухати предмети соціальної
громадянської галузі тобто історія
України всесвітня історія основи
правознавства інтегрованих курсів і
громадянської освіти
А всі хто хочуть далі продовжувати
слухати перейти на YouTube там не
обмежена кількість людей які можуть
приєднатися і ми передаємо слово
наступні секції риси Іванівна вина
слухаєте ви нас чуєте Доброго дня ми
передаємо слово і тимчасово відмикаємося
Дякуємо дуже
Слава Україні Слава нашим ЗСУ нашим
героїчним військам які захищають нас які
дарує нам працювати слід складні частини
Шановні колеги як вже говорили в
попередньо в зв'язку із розвитку діями
російсько-української війни
мали можливість переглянути програми
низки кабінетів в тому числі було
переглянуто програму з усного
правознавства з громадянської освіти і з
історії і я зараз хочу відразу Оскільки
ми вже трошки
випускаємося із нашого часу я хочу
відразу передати слово керівнику групи
робочої яка
займалася мусила змії не в програму
компанію Тетяні РЕ
форми
пані Тетяна ремахи Національної академії
кандидат педагогічних наук старший
дослідник Шановні колеги я теж дуже вас
прошу хто зараз не говорить відключили
мікрофони тому що зайвого шуму багато
дякую пані Тетяна вам дякую що запросили
представляю результати робочої групи які
затверджує предметною комісією
Міністерства освіти науки України і
власне тепер є членами вже рисовально
озвучила чому відбувалося зміну в цих
програмах наголошую що зміни коли
точковими і зараз я дуже коротко
протягом 7-8 хвилин познайомимо вас
змінами перше на що я звернула вашу
увагу це не те що змінилося логіка курсу
Подивіться будь ласка тепер ми йдемо від
людини через справу до держави тоді як у
попередній програмі логіка була від
держави через права до людини тобто
тепер вивчення предмета
розпочинаємо наприклад основоположних
понять як людська гідність Свобода
рівність справедливість Я думаю що це ті
цінності які ми маємо пошановувати
особливо у цей дуже складний для нашої
держави час і відповідно зроблені такі
акценти основні те що людина є найвищою
соціальною цінністю демократичного
суспільства а право виступає
інструментом Справедливості у зв'язку з
цим змінено і певні положення пояснюємо
та зміст програми
пояснювальний записці Додано короткий
опис змісту та основних положень
розділів програми це для того щоб
вчитель розумів
логіку
побудови і викладу такого матеріалу і
для того щоб закцентувати його увагу на
основних питаннях змісту додамо також
таблицю за житловим описом
компетентнісного потенціалу предмету
того чого раніше саме в нашій програмі
не було а такий елемент був присутній у
багатьох інших
нова програма а також
викладено деякі зауваги щодо
формувального освіти і так це я говорила
про зміну пояснювальної записів
детальніше про те як якими є особливості
навчання учнів основ правознавства
читайте методичних реконізаціях
Міністерства освіти і науки там цю кожну
позицію ми розши
рилися
назви розділ який відбулися
у зв'язку з новою логікою програм розділ
один нині називаються основи теорії
права і держави тоді як у попередньому
варіанті програми він мав назву основи
теорії держави і права розділ 2 тепер
має назву реалізація права
фактично правовідносини правопорушення
юридична відповідальність є нічим іншим
як реалізація права і врешті-решт
повністю змінено і назву і зміст розділу
5 нині він називається правнуча професія
тоді попередня назва була юриста в
нашому житті Потім були прийняті
відповідні професійні стандарти і в
зв'язку з цим ми змінили назву розділу і
його змістове наповнення подивимося які
нові питання з'явилися у змісті і
зрозуміло вони
пов'язані знову з логікою програми і
відповідно тими акцентами якими ми
увиразнили у зв'язку з ситуацією в нашій
державі І власне зміною пріоритетів і В
самій юридичній науці в шкільному
правознавстві у вступі до основ
правознавства тепер Ми не говоримо про
структуру підручника про те як будуть
побудовані уроки а зразу переходимо до
дуже важливих питань це якими були
соціальні передумови виникнення цікава
які його фундаментальні засади
відповідно і чому людина є залишається
найвищою соціальною цінність Причому я
зверну Вашу увагу що всі питання так чи
інакше дітям відомі і з початкової школи
з курсу досліджуємо світ і відповідно з
інших курсів в тому числі історії і тому
тут треба обов'язково залучати їхні
знання відповідно їх слід ставлення і
їхній
міркування щодо цих понять у розділі
першому Додано питання цінність права у
розвитку
він я прошу Вимкнути мікрофон Дякую У
розділі третьому у зв'язку з новою
логікою програми він починається блоком
питань пов'язано з правами людини права
людини покоління прав людини механізми
захисту прав та свобод людини і
громадянин в Україні Додано такі питання
як демократія верховенство права і
змінено і вилучено з
першого розділу питання державний лад а
Додано У цьому розділі питання
конституційної
влади і в зв'язку з тим що зміни
вносилися у зв'язку з повномасштабною
зброєю агресією Російської Федерації
проти України Додано питання правовий
режим надзвичайного стану за правовий
режим обмінного стану
у розділі четвертому де мова йде про
неповнолітніх як учасників низки
правових відносин з'являються такі нові
питання як договори тобто надвобленими
літніх учасники договірних правовідносин
власність неповнолітніх дуже важливе
нині питання спадкування і спадщина а
також права дитини та її захист я лише
вибрала ці нові питання Утім якщо ви
подивитесь на змістов програми ви бачите
ви побачите де їхні місце вони не стоять
отак от одним абзацу тобто відповідно до
галузі права відповідно там є цінові
запитання
наголошувала Що повністю змінився зміст
5-го розділу п'ятий розділ має дуже
важливий значення тому що зараз
укладається стандарт профільної
середньої освіти і тому він носить до
профільних таких характер а також
орієнтаційні у зв'язку з цим і виникли
питання які ми включили у єдиний розділ
призначення правника у сучасному
демократичному суспіль
стві а вони чи професії охорона
правопорядку і правозахисна діяльність
тобто ми говоримо тепер не лише про
юристів А про правників у цілому і
Останній мій блок короткої інформації
буде присвячений практичним заняттям з
предмету наголошую що і в навчальній
програмі і методичних рекомендаціях
сказано що практичні заняття є
обов'язковим складником навчання учнів
основ правознавства в дев'ятому класі
які ж нові теми практичне заняття І що з
ними робити Я зараз про це скажу і так у
першому році у першому розділі є нова
тема соціальне призначення держави
натомість анульовану тему вилучену тему
соціальні норми в житті людини у другому
розділі уточнену тему практичного
заняття обставини що виключає і тепер
вона звучить Так обставини що виключають
юридичну відповідальність
у третьому розділі Додано дві надважливі
теми це зобов'язання держави у сфері
прав людини повага захисту забезпечення
бо тепер це практичне заняття відповідає
змісту розділу і друге - це особливості
додержання прави свого людини
громадянина право виконують інтересів і
юридичних осіб в умовах надзвичайного
або воєнного стану Я вам дуже раджу якщо
ви обрати саме цю тему або про
практичного заняття тому що я сподіваюся
що ви війна скінчується а саме зараз
вона дуже актуальна в четвертому розділі
ми
поміркували і Додано багато
Додано дві теми які стосуються власне
того що наші діти зараз роблять в
інтернеті або вони можуть так чи інакше
бути
і можуть належати права інтелектуальної
власності а також там де криміна цікаво
Додано тему захист прав дитини від
жорстокого поводження в експлуатації або
інших форм насильства і останній розділ
п'ятий теж зазнали змін у темах
практичних занять вони абсолютно нові
професійна етика правника тому що ми
говоримо про призначення правника в
демократичному суспільстві про те що
бажано провести зустріч з представниками
правничих професій або правил
захисниками що наразі можливо Тим паче
якщо
не дуже б хотілося Але якщо ми будемо
працювати онлайн це легше Організувати а
також дуже важлива тема і яку Ми довго
обговорювали певні корективи були
внесені На предметній комісії де
затверджували зміни в програмі Це права
та обов'язки неповнолітніх під час
комунікації з представниками
правоохоронного органу і нарешті останні
зауваги і це останній слайд щодо
практичних занять Зверніть увагу на ті
особливості на які на якій на яких
наголошено і в пояснювальній записці
навчальної програми і в методичних
рекомендаціях Міністерство освіти і
науки України на новий навчальний рік і
так практичне заняття є обов'язковим
кожна практичне заняття має свою тему і
ця тема не співпадає з теми теоретичного
уроку
увага учитель може обирати тему
практичного заняття із запропонованому в
програмі переліку тобто не всі теми які
є в програмі дослухайтесь уважно До
цього вони мають бути вписані в журнал і
проведені бігом похибцем аби тільки
виконати програму ні ви обираєте раніше
такої позиції в програмі не було Тобто
було 10 тем практичних занять і всі вони
обов'язково там де ви бачите перелік на
одну тему апендику ви можете обрати одну
з них
безумовно практичні заняття найкраще
побудовувати на діяльність підході і
тому тут передбачається
застосування активного навчання учнів
роботи з різноманітними джерелами А
вчитель тут виступає організатором і
консультантом самостійно дослідницької
або творчої діяльності учнів
і все про зміну в програмі дуже коротко
я бажаю Нам усім вашим сім'ям і нашим
державним органам нашій державі Миру
Надії
встановлення оновлення і сподіваюся що
Ми продовжуємо цей навчальний рік бо ми
вчителі а вчителі багато чого значать
дякую
якщо є питання будь ласка в чаті і я
можу відповідати
Раїси Іванівна Я закінчила свою
презентацію А я хотіла подякувати панове
хотіла дуже наперед це сказати членом
робочої групи у нас була така дуже
професійна компетентна група це було
юрист вчителів ви завершили Да я зараз
договорю я хочу подякувати Олегу музі
який був експертом нашої групи
Наталі бецій яка представляє
відповідно сектор я хочу подякувати
особливо Вікторії Павловський Кравчук
яка під обстрілами в Харкові
продовжувала і продовжує зараз працювати
в нашій вже не в нашій робочій групі але
працювала
росіянка яка це все організовувала
відповідно В'ячеславу майорському
особливо Олександр козирок Бо саме
завдяки
їй внесені такі ціннісно-мистові питання
і всім тим хто був небайдужим до роботи
Тому ми маємо зараз інакшу кращу
цінність та смислову і гарно програму
свого боку обіцяю розміщувати в
соціальних мережах будь-який методичні
розробки Заходьте дивіться підписуйтесь
на сторінку відділу суспільнознавчої
освіти я там щедро ділюся В мене всі
вільні для копіювання і я буду вам рада
служити нашому предмету нашому методиці
і нашій державі дякую дякую
Ми дякуємо Тетяна Олексіївна за чудову
презентацію і теж Велике вам спасибі за
ту роботу яку ви проводите Я хочу
передати слово панові Петру кензору
доктору педагогічних наук координатор
освітніх проектів асоціації викладачів
історії та суспільних дисциплін нова
доба Петро кендзєр очолював робочу групу
яка працювала над внесенням змін до
програм з громадянської освіти будь
ласка пане Петре вам слово
Дорогі колеги вітаю вас усіх і я би
хотів почати саме з того чим закінчила
моя колега пані Тетяна тільки що з того
щоб хочу подякувати
усім членам нашої робочої групи які
впродовж літа
відповідально і професійно виконано не
лише свій професійний обов'язок але й
також і громадянський
особливо хочу подякувати пані Тетяні
Ремех яка не була офіційно членом нашої
робочої групи але впродовж всього часу
нашої роботи вона долучалася до нашої
роботи і надавала нам неоціненну
допомогу у ході підготовки наших
продуктів нашої діяльності
ось Шановні колеги я хотів би почати з
того що курс громадянської освіти в
порівнянні з іншими предметами шкільними
має порівняно невелику історію
цього
тринавчальні роки вивчається впродовж
трьох навчальних років вивчається курс
громадянської освіти в
10 класах навчальних закладів України
ми маємо невеликий досвід але за своїм
потенціалом і актуальністю особливо у
теперішній час Цей курс є
важливим і актуальним не лише у
формуванні
ідентичності українців не лише у
формуванні конкретних компетентностей
відповідального громадянина а передусім
Цей курс є надзвичайно важливим для
консолідації українського суспільства
оскільки це питання Ця проблема є зараз
життєво важлива для нашого українського
суспільства
у ході вдосконалення програми з
громадянської освіти у своїй роботі ми
намагалися не лише приводити у
відповідність і сучасними реаліями певні
змістові лінії тих чи інших розділів
програми але ми також звертали увагу на
методичні підходи до роботи
задля того щоб посилити передусім
практичний вимір
громадянської освіти у школах України
тому що громадянська освіта стає власне
громадянською освітою коли вона виходить
за межі школи коли вона
виходить
[музика]
УВІР життя місцевої громади і саме Від
це намагалися відобразити у
процесі нашої роботи саме саме з цією
метою оновленій редакції навчальної
програми ми особливу увагу звернули на
практичні завдання до кожного розділу
сформулювали їх переважно у форматі
питальних речень що спонукає учнів чи
учениць до дослідження
означеної тої чи іншої проблеми
наприклад у практичному блоці ми додали
такі теми для практичних занять якісь
способи та шляхи цивільних осіб було
бджолиного кон
флікту та своїх близь
ких у випадку небезпеки
громадянський опір збройні агресії
Російської Федерації в Україні які
основні наративні інформаційних війн як
міжнародні гуманітарні організації
надають або повинні надавати допомогу у
випадку надзвичайних ситуацій як
волонтери різних країн підтримують
Україну в умовах збройного конфлікту та
інші
як і наголошували А моя колега пані
Тетяна Ремех
усі практичні завдання до того чи іншого
розділу їхня тематика є рекомендованими
і ви можете обирати поміж них ми
рекомендуємо
все-таки використовувати 3-4 практичних
заняття до кожного розділу їхню тематику
ви можете обирати як із програми так і
здійснювати певну модифікацію цих тем
для практичних занять
виходячи із тих реалій у яких ви зараз
проживаєте із реалії місцевої громади
інших особливостей тощо
А зараз коротко по змінах на кожну по
кожному розділу
хочу відразу сказати що загалом
структура і назва розділів до курсу
громадянської освіти залишилися без змін
ми внесли лише деякі окремих розділах
сплочкові зміни в окремі на рівні
введення тої чи іншої нової теми яка є
особливо актуальною зараз
розділ 1 особистість та її ідентичність
особливих змін на змістовій лінії Ми не
вносили до цього розділу він в принципі
в оригінальній програмі непогано
виписаний у програмі але хочемо
наголосити що
основним таким маленьким дивом вивчення
цього розділу разом з учнями є відповідь
на запитання Що означає бути українцем
українкою в умовах збройної агресії
проти України
розділ 2
права та свободи людини
силу природи війни
та пригоди не перебувають загрозою
суттєвого та системного порушення
користування
підприємства
обмеженню особливо було
підключіть будь ласка мікрофони нічого
не чути користуватися
комп'ютером
Шановні колеги Якщо вам не цікаво
Вийдіть будь ласка ви включили
презентацію хтось із Черкаської області
Ну Слухайте ну совість Майте з 11-ї
години просимо вимкнути мікрофони Хто не
говорить
Продовжуйте вибачте
Петро Іванович включіть мікрофон тепер
дивіться будь ласка
мене хтось вимкнув ступно але я вже
знову з вами добре спеціально для
вирішення ось саме цих питань в розділі
права та свободи людини Було введено
нову тему яка називається права людини
та Права дитини в умовах збройного
конфлікту
у ході вивчення цієї теми окрім питань
забезпечення та захисту прав людини та
прав дитини в умовах збройного конфлікту
десятикласники матимуть можливість
ознайомитися із основними положеннями
міжнародного гуманітарного права
розділ 3 людина в соціокультурному
просторі там є в оригінальній програмі
була і є така тема мова йде про
конфлікти і зокрема ми в рамках цієї
теми посилили увагу до вивчення явища
конфліктів мова йде про війну як
найжорстокіший прояв збройного конфлікту
і також в рамках цього розділу ми додали
тему щодо громадянського округу як
відповіді на виклики часу і нашої
реальності
у розділі 4 демократичне суспільство
було закцентовано увагу на ролі
громадських організацій у розбудові
громадянського суспільства але особливо
на активності кожного громадянина
у ході вияву його громадянської
компетентності і була також
актуалізована роль волонтерства як
важливої складової загальної
громадянської культури
в умовах війни особливо го значення
набуває розгляд питань що стосується
світу інформації
це свого роду наш Другий фронт якому
перебуває ми вже тепер усі не тільки
збройні сили України і саме тому до
розділу 5-го світ інформації та
медіаграмотність було внесено теж низку
змін а саме посилена увага до агресивних
проявів інформаційних війн в онлайн
просторі до інформаційних маніпуляцій
пропаганди конкретизоване питання що
стосується складових інформаційної
безпеки
розділ 6 економіка ніби він так і Мирний
але якщо так поверхнево підійти до його
вивчення і аналізу і ми зокрема в рамках
чи його цього розділу який присвячений
вивченням основ економічних знань та
фінансової грамотності ми додали теми
які важливі з точки зору економічного
життя в Україні в умовах військового
стану
зокрема введено такі поняття як
економічна безпека та соціальна держава
як економічні санкції
привернуто увагу до таких економічних
понять як зміна попиту та пропозиції
доходів та видатків державного бюджету у
воєнний час
здійснено акцент на особливості введення
домогосподарства в умовах військового
стану але не лише і ми взяли такі
конкретні випадки коли мова йде про
домогосподарство в зоні бойових дій коли
мова йде про домогосподарство в окупації
коли мова йде про домогосподарство в
тилу Які їхні сфери виживання діяльності
активності відповідальності і так далі
ми це намагалися такі аспекти включити
саме в цю програму і насамкінець розділ
сім Україна та світ я скажу вам так що
чекають у мирний час Цей розділ потребує
постійного свого змістового оновлення
десь у ході
наших засідань чи поміж нами нашими
засіданнями Україна вже змінила також
свій міжнародний політичний статус і
стала кандидатом у члени Європейського
Союзу тобто зміни на міжнародному рівні
і в українському вимірі вони
відбуваються дуже швидко і дай боже
оптимістично для нас усіх і ми в цьому
вимірі акцентували передусім тезу про те
що збройна агресія Росії проти України
це не лише загроза для України
це є виклик світовому порядку і це є
виклик демократії та демократичним
цінностям У цьому розділі також
активізовано явище міжнародної
солідарності у випадку глобальних загроз
а також доповнено цей розділ блоком про
співпрацю і інтеграцію України і НАТО
ми вважаємо нову редакцію програми яку
ми пропонуємо на ваш розгляд
такою яка відповідає викликам часу але
вона може мати свою успішну
імплементацію освітнього просторі лише
за умови посвяченого і відповідального
підходу з боку педагогів вчителів
громадянської освіти але не лише їх мова
йде також про
у контексті вивчення громадянської
освіти мова йде також і про співпрацю із
батьками мова йде про співпрацю з
членами місцевих громад і з місцевими
активістами тобто з усіма тими хто є
частинкою нашого українського
громадянського суспільства дякую вам
дуже якщо є запитання я відповім вам у
чаті
Дякую пане Петре також надзвичайно
великих концептуальних змін у назва
знали програми з історії і я зараз
великий приємністю передаю слово пані
Людмилі Гриневич доктор історичних наук
директорці українського
науково-дослідного та освітнього центру
вивчення голодомору буде Грек in Ukraine
будь ласка пані людмило вам слово для
презентації змін до програм з історії
Дякую Лариса Іванівна Доброго дня
вельмишановні колеги
Я хочу перш за все подякувати
Міністерство освіти і науки інституту
модернізації змісту освіти за надану
можливість нам обговорити результати
нашої кількамісячної роботи щоб була
спрямована на несення цільозних змін на
оновлення змісту програм з історичних
дисциплін
нашу робочу групу складали досить відомі
вам з цим провідні методисти педагоги і
науковці Це був такий Тандем наука і
освіта
мова йшла про внесення змін до програми
аж від 7 до 11-го класу Тобто це історія
України Це є всесвітня історія На мою
думку робоча група провела просто
неймовірно роботу І до того ж
непростих умовах і підготурен і
приміщуючись Україною от зараз в судячи
по всьому Олексіївка зараз у нас
приєднатися тому що трошки зміщення часу
на проведення нашого заходу він вже на
зйомках тобто популяризація історичного
знання це важливо тобто напевно буде
сенс колись про це все написати але вже
після нашої Перемоги зараз я хочу дуже
коротко
позначити вам її мотивацію нашої роботи
а головне окреслити які завдання перед
нами стояли і як ми їх разом вирішили ну
перш за все Я хочу відзнати відзначити
шкільна історична освіта - це зброя
на превеликий жаль це не є метафора
ми всі розуміємо що це реальність вже
абсолютно зрозуміло що Російська
Федерація сьогодні здійснює геноцид в
Україні і шкільна історична освіта - це
один із інструментів здійснення цього
злочину
ви прекрасно знаєте і бачите що триває
це так і на нашу систему освіти на
реформу нуш яка бачите є неприпустимою з
погляду окупантів бо вона віддаляє
українську освіту від Російської
тривають спроби насадження на тимчасово
окупованих українських на території
Російської системи освіти і перш за все
історичною триває викрадання вивезення
натирання Росії наших дітей і спроби їх
денацифікувати
нарешті триває переслідування наших
педагогів наших освітян Я думаю ви чули
стане інтерв'ю одного з рашистів на
Комсомольський правді з пропозиціями
примусити наших педагогів в'їзд їх
українські банківські картки і
організувати для них Гулак з тим аби
Навчіть родину любіть і от усе це
інструменти здійснення злочину генотипу
а намір тут один і він навіть не
приховується намір нищення національної
ідентичності українського народу і
досягти цього прагнуть двома способами
шляхом переплавки свідомості одних і
фізичного нищення інших от переплавки
свідомості це саме про історичні освіти
Ну але зброя ми з вами Це дуже добре
знаємо
використовується не лише для нападу але
для оборони напевно розуміння цього Ось
і спонукала нас досить такий великий
колектив і науковці ви педагогів і
методистів
взятися до досить складну роботу
над програмами з тим аби
переосмислити їх зміст і скорегувати їх
у необхідному для наших учнів для нас
українців
Я хочу зробити одне дуже важливе
застереження Так що ми добре
усвідомлюємо що історична освіта - це
зброя однак демократична і цивілізована
держава якою є Україна не може
сподіваюсь ніколи не дозволить собі
вибудовувати систему історичної освіти
ґрунтуючись на історичних міфах на
пропагандистських гаслах на політика
ідеологічних ідеологемах Нехай в погляду
когось і там корисних чи потрібно
тому я хочу абсолютно відповідально
наголосити що основним пріоритетом нашої
роботи був перегляд і переосмислення
змісту наявних програм з історичних
дисциплін з погляду їх відповідності в
сучасному рівню наукового знання тобто
між ідеологією наукою пріоритет
безсумнівна і безперечно віддавався
науці Я думаю що всім Добре відомо що
наші програми з історичною дисциплін
вона оновлювалися і раніше причому не
раз наші фахівці науковці провели
поглиблений аналіз змісту змістовного
наповнення наших програм і це аналіз
засвідчив перш за все Мова йде саме про
курси з історії України просто про
нагальну потребу саме концептуального
переопрацювання наших програм
Я би хотіла
зауважити що просто нема де Правди діти
наші програми з історичних дисциплін не
усіх звісно але б дуже дуже багатьох
моментах концептуальному плані просто
безбожна відстали від досягнень і
вітчизняної і світової академічної науки
тобто у нас виник і на превеликий жаль
закріпився на рівні вже в підручника
творення досить такий серйозний розрив в
багатьох моментах між наукою і освітою
Ну я думаю що напевно вона в цьому перш
за все наших академічних науковців
знають це на власному досвіді тому що
науковці Вони переважно схильні
ставитися до освіти як до чогось такого
несерйозного другорядного Ну війна це
виправила війна це виправила
Отже врешті наша робоча група Взяла на
себе досить таки відповідальне завдання
переопрацювати програму з тим аби
передовсім у концептуальному плані
позбавити їх залишків по совєтської
історіографічної традиції і підтягнути
їх до рівня сучасного наукового знання
завдання це було досить непростим ми
працювали кілька місяців нашої роботи
тривала і наших засідання був зустрічі
тривалий по 5 по 7 годин але ми
впоралися ну передусім тому що
команду яка вже говорила склав такий
чудовий Тандем академічних науковців і
високопрофесійних педагогів і я би
хотіла тут просто назвати вона деяких з
них Це є Костянтин баханов цей Павло
Полянський цей Юлія Малієнко цей Валерія
Островський цей Мар'ян мудрий І я також
невимовно вдячна наше академічний
науковці на Вадиму айству і Наталії
Старченко Євген Сергій та вже почалося
дідусенко і окремо вдячність хочу
висловити наші методичній раді тому що
розумієте ми очікували
рецензію але ми дістали потужну
підтримку допомогу ми працювали як одна
команда І от допомога нашої методичної
ради наших колег вона була
надзвичайно цінною надзвичайною
абсолютно ясно що і після нас далі
робота над удосконаленням програм з
історії буде тривати але я як керівник
цієї робочої групи абсолютно впевнена в
тому що закладені зараз
2022 році зміст наших програм нові
концептуальні підходи вони
залишатимуться і слугуватимуть
теоретичною основою такою базою для
укладання і модальних програм надалі
інде написання підручників
тепер що стосується змісту Дорогі колеги
ви ж розумієте що в мене особливий тут
там ми мусите як вноси
ли від Давньої Русі хронологічна і
сучасної війни Росії проти України у нас
є всесвітня історія тому якщо я почала
зараз вам тут системно викладати ті
новації зміни на дорозі ми з вами
працювали я так впевнена до
напевно до ночі тому я все-таки з вашого
дозволу
дуже коротко і на загальних рисах
окреслимо вам передусім суть змін які
були внесені до програм з історії
України 10-11 класу це те що ми сьогодні
з вами живемо А почну все-таки не
змістовного наповнення хоча для мене як
академічного науковця це було би
звичайно природним я почну з кількох
зауважень таких методичних і тут я
вдячна колезі пані Юлії Малієнко
Я фактично озвучую сформульовані в неї
думки
перше на думку наших методистів членів
робочої групи
зовнішні ефект збільшення наших програм
не свідчить про її перенавантаження Я
хочу на цьому особливо наголосити тому
що ви побачите програми педагоко
видається що вони стали за обсягом
більше мова не йде
перевантаження програми Ми дуже багатьох
моментах
конкретно-історичні матеріали ми їх
скорочували Але в даному разі нам йшлося
про концептуальне перезавантаження
дуже багато положень попередніх версій
програм потребували у зв'язку з цим
конкретизації і тому ті доповнення які
ми робили
коли робили це для того щоб
полегшити роботу нашого вчителя тому що
ми дуже добре усвідомлюємо що зараз
склалася така досить складна
парадоксальна ситуація коли зміст нашим
програм багатьох концептуальних моментах
він не відбітив не відбитий в
підручниках і тому це потребуватиме від
наших педагогів талановитих додаткової
роботи але ми також я наперед хочу
сказати що ми теж я подключилась с лучше
сюда я зараз
ми наперед думаємо про те щоб
створити таку цілу миску вебінарів які
будуть стосуватися конкретно
зміни внесених наші програми і ми
спробуємо підготувати для вас також
певне кола публікації посилань на
джерела активних з тим щоб наш вчитель
ці такі компанії часи мав можливості
добре готуватися до
наших уроків друге ми серйозно думали
над тим або була забезпечена цілісність
нашої програми і як нам здається ми
змогли цього дося
гти як наявності наскрізних понять і
положень серед них українська
громадянська нація ідентичність зміни
відомості людина соціальні етнічні
релігійні групи
старих взаємодії Пропаганда як
інструмент впливу на свідомість а в
окремих випадках і інструмент
підбурювання і здійснення геноциду і тут
ми говоримо з вами про чотири геноциди
які були
вчинені
сталінським і нацистським імперськими
тоталітарним режимом це є Голодомор це
голокост і депортація українських татар
і ми говоримо також з вами і про сучасну
війну Росії проти України
[музика]
по-третє у наших змінах
ми акцентуємо увагу лише на тому що ми
це особливо стосується програм 10-11
класу що ми
досить серйозна і це теж збільшила обсяг
програми Ми дуже серйозно поставились до
орієнтовних тем для есе і для практичних
і творчих робіт
наші педагоги
члени нашої робочої групи вважають Я
думаю це абсолютно справедливо що в
умовах пріоритету нинішніх умовах
дистанційного навчання Ось така
діяльність буде розширювати простір
взаємодії дитини і педагога новим
складником Також у нас стала рубрика
позакласне читання тому що у нас Ми
зіткнулися наприклад з проблемою
пов'язано з тим що скажімо Ті теми які
ми історичні опрацьовуємо там на рівні
20 століття в курсе в історію України
література викладаються ці теми вже в 11
класі Тобто ми знайшли радилися але
знайшли підхід відповідно до якого ми
маємо розділ тепер такий потужний
позакласне читання які презентує
класичну сучасну українську літературу
якраз дотичну історичним подіям явищем і
це звичайно стане дуже в нагоді тим хто
буде бажати збагатити джерельну базу
попрацювати з різними типами джерел тому
що літератури це теж
щось і джерела це один з типів джерел з
якими повинні працювати історію тепер
дуже коротко
по
змістовному наповненню це матеріали
10-11 класу у структурі 10-11 класу
тобто 20 і початок XXI століття отже
колеги перше головне і основне ми
активно працювали над тим аби увиразнити
провідну тенденцію 20 століття
провідна тенденція ХХ століття Це не
безкінечні революції
це по суті по совєтській підхід провідна
тенденція 20 століття і тобі
гуманітаристці це тенденція краху
імперії і послання національних держав
Отже якщо ми побачимо подивимось з вами
на 20 століття оця тенденція краху
імперії які трималися століттями
спочатку більше після Першої світової
війни війни
крах континентальних чотирьох
континентальних імперій постання
англійської національних держав а після
Другої світової війни крах колоніальних
імперії і повстання змогу такі низки
національних держав Так в цьому аспекті
Ми робимо наголос і особливе значення на
історії Української Народної Республіки
повстання Української Народної
Республіки як національні держави Отже
наши Учні повинні зрозуміти що всі
загальні тенденції краху імперії
повстання національних держав Україна
так само як і інші європейські народи
була Може сказати тобі стрімі Тобто ми
теж створили власну національну державу
одна з ключових тем Це
я вже говорила проходить наскрізною
лінією проблематика формування
громадянської нації Отже Українська
Народна Республіка зробила досить багато
для того щоб йшов процес консолідації
оцієї громадянської нації
також одна з ключових тем - Це
Політехнічний підхід тобто для нас є і
повинні бути однаково важливими всі
народи які творили історичний ландшафт
України але це абсолютно І зовсім не
заперечує особливої державотворчої і на
це творчі ролі українців навпаки
далі якщо ми дивимося з вами на 17
початок
20-х років тому ми говоримо про
міждержавні війни до вибору боротьби за
українську незалежність
тут ми будемо поняття
реімперіалізації яке є актуальним
сьогодні пояснюю багато чого у сучасній
війні вільні Росії проти України але ми
фактично
[музика]
називаємо речі своїми іменами і
пояснюємо
те що
міждержавні війни між Росією і Україною
на це були не війни
з боку України Це були війни за
збереження Незалежності але з боку Росії
це було не стільки війни за встановлення
за комуністичної ідеалу скільки це були
вільні за відновлення колишнього
імперського простору Отже я хочу
особливо звернути вашу увагу на те що ми
дуже добре Прописали усі інструменти
імперіалізації з одного боку це
постання і створення низки маріонеткових
класів держав Я хочу особливо відзначити
що Знаєте друзі колеги ми в процесі
роботи над нашими програмами ми мали
величезну кількість консультацій
спеціалістами членами робочими робочої
групи і нам на рівні навіть понятійного
апарату доводилось проводити цілий
дискусії от якраз оці маріонетка
виходять держави один цьому прикладі Я
вам просто коротко це поясню Подивіться
якщо в нас були скажімо просто
квазі-держава квазі-держава на думку
юристів які нам пояснювали
що ти справа це не досить повноцінна
держава тобто якісь сутність однак які
характеризують Інститут держави тут
відсутній і в цьому плані навіть
українську народну
рисуючість юридичної точки зору можна
теж було десь оцінювати як увазі держави
так якщо ми беремо визначено
маріонеткова держава ми чітко вказуємо
що вона є несамостійна А кимоськерована
але це є повноцінна держава маріонеткова
держава тому от В нас іде цей дискусій
ми і вживаємо оце визначення маріонеткою
квазі-держави Тобто це зовсім не є якісь
там метафори
епітети це чітко
визначений нами цей понятійний ряд після
наших довгих наших консультацій з нашими
спеціалістами між іншим Те саме
стосується
національні меншини над інвести
зрозуміли чи замінити Це на етнічні
спільноти але тоді українці теж етнічна
спільнота розумієте тобто дуже-дуже
велика робота була проведена у довкола
формування оцього понятійного апарату
Отже
один шлях створення
маріонетки квазів держави а інший
інструмент - це захоплення території
експансія збройним шляхом і Отут я вам
як історик хочу сказати що ви знаєте
Дорогі колеги ми надто довго
десятиліттями боялися називати речі
своїми іменами
унаслідок того що Ми боялися образити
наших сусідів образити Росію якісь в
системі освіти застосувати якісь
визначення які можуть бачити формувати
якісь фобії ну в даному випадку я кажу
про те що в нашій програмі ми вживаємо
визначення окупація
бачите це в Території українського
народної республіки і це також не є Ані
метафорою а не перебільшенням через те
що ще в часі
головування інституту українського
національної пам'яті юхновського були
вже опубліковані наукові досліди які
чітко показують і вказують на те що в
1920 році на терен Україні
Російською Федерацією мого заведено
військо 995
тисяч бійців мобілізованих з внутрішніх
губерній Російської Федерації І от саме
вони саме ця армія становилась советскую
ладу в Україні Власне кажучи за всіма
однаками це характеризується присутність
Вибачте такого війська на терміні
України характеризується як окупація
тому ми застосовуємо цей термін окупація
і далі ми аналізуємо чим була Україна у
складі Советского Союзу і чим власне був
студентський союз і це є надзвичайно
важливо
в світовій гуманістиці вже давно
переважно утвердився підхід відповідно
до якого совєтські Союз оцінюється як
держава імперського типу Ну і колегія
якщо б в нас був час і можливості ми
могли про це більш докладно поговорити
але я вам хочу сказати що досить
тривалий час віддавав гуманітаристика не
розглядала собі починається державою
типу і переважно Це сталося тому що вся
Пропаганда бачите знову роль і значення
пропаганди так ось ця Пропаганда
Советского Союзу завжди будувались на
антиіперській і на антиколоніальні
риториці Але після розпаду Советского
Союзу і повстання на його терміни цілої
вниз і готовий національний державах
виник цілий напрям в інтеріології
відповідно до якого більшість
спеціалістів в Західній і наші
вітчизняних гуманітаристи це навіть в
російській вже давно трактуються детские
Союз як державу імперського типу Отже
якщо це віскіз був імперією
союз був тоталітарною імпеєю тут я хочу
звернути вашу увагу на те що
розведення хронологічних меж Ми не
можемо говорити про тоталітаризм і
обмежувати його виключно до мою
сталінізму Вибачте за всіма сутністьними
характеристиками
і ландшафти
тоталіта аж до середини 80-х років Отже
якщо ми говоримо про совєтські Союз як
про Імперію безперечно постає питання
про статус України чим була Україна і
ось тут колеги я хочу звернути вашу
увагу на те що справді ми віддаємо
пріоритет науки над ідеологією тому що
існує велика Спокуса сьогодні назвати
Україну колонію у складі Советского
Союзу але на думку досить авторитетних
науковців світового рівня і адреса
це можливо буде зробити після проведення
додаткових досліджень Отже ті
Дослідження які проведені сьогодні
середні
літературазнавчий доводять що Україна
була колонія але те що стосується
історії економіки тобто
тут ще працювати в цьому напрямі тому ми
застосовуємо більш нейтральний термін
який в перспективі не виключає
визначення України як колонії але більш
нейтральний термін який визначається як
залежна територія Отже
Советский Союз як тоталітарна імперія
Україна як залежна територія
в нас надзвичайно важливим розуміти оце
поєднання
імперської і комуністичної зброї в
сутності Советского Союза Я вам дуже
коротко це проясню на темі голодомору
Отже коли колеги беремо з вами наші
старі програми що ми бачимо ми бачимо
початок електризації примусової від 29
року
ми бачимо тему посилення хлібозаготівлі
і наслідки Голодомору як ми можемо з
вами виокремити особливість України і
скажімо інших регіонів Де так само був
момент якщо і потужна колективізація і
розкуркулення і хлібозаготівлі так само
проводилися на теренах ті хто детских
республік але ситуація Ну звичайно
звісно те що стосується нищення мови
нищення інтелігенції Це була особливість
але це такий якщо ми дивимося на
голодомор як на наслідок діє одночасно
її і комуністичної і імперської зброї
тут все стає на своїй місцях тому що для
нас скажімо не так важливо Який обсяг
збіжжя в процесі хлібозаготівлі вибрала
держава як те як він був розподілений Це
абсолютно зрозуміло тобто чи це
збільшення залишилося на території
України і чи українська влада мала
можливості з ними розпоряджатися чи він
був вивезений скажімо на експорт а також
на внутрішнього союзній ринки розумієте
Отже надзвичайно важливо проблематика
яка стосується також рівня свідомості я
вам говорила що ми
наповнюють усіх наших програмах
наскрізно проходить проблематика
формування ідентичності як себе
самоусвідомлювали
політичні настрої знову таки
повертаючись до Епохи голодомору можна
сказати що
колосальна різниця між тими повстаннями
масовими виступами які були в Україні і
на інших теренах Советского Союзу
полягала в тому що тут соціальні мотиви
дуже тісно перепліталися з національними
грубо кажучи Якщо десь там поголожі
кричали геть комуну то в Україні кричали
поверніть українську Народну Республіку
поверніть Петлюру і це є надзвичайно
важливим в тому що наявність в тих
антимперських настроїв наявність
національної свідомості яка протягом
всіх десятиліть советскому Союзу
послідовно вміщалась для формування
так званого сув’язкового чоловіка
далі Друга світова війна тут багато що
можна було би говорити але я хочу вам
сказати наступне на думку нашої робочої
групи поволі поступово значення
викладання історії Другої світової війни
буде
змінюватись тому контексті що ми другий
світовій війні будемо оприділяти тим
меншу і меншу увагу і справа навіть тут
не в тому побідоб'єкції яке притаманне
Російській Федерації в тому що на жаль
ми маємо ту частку нашу війну і наші
голови наші серця всі наші думки вони
будуть більше втілені на осмислення
сучасної російської війни тому
проблематики проблематиці Другої
світової війни ми дещо скоротили в
контексті конкретно історичних
матеріалів і деякі моменти надзвичайно
концептуальні такі моменти ми їх
звичайно ви провели увиразнили умови і
де
про поняття колабораціонізм Отже
стосовно України визначення
колабораціонізму не є Наукова
виправданим поляки давно вже цього не
роблять абсолютно чому Тому що це
поняття колабораціонізм Які в
англійській мові є абсолютно нормальним
білки
для України внаслідок того щоб були
створені потужні оці політика
ідеологічні міфи це поняття абсолютно
чітко Має
конотацію причетні до скажімо Голокосту
крім того Україна на відміну від Європи
скажімо на відміну від Франції і уряду у
вірші не мало власної державності була
колонією Її населення так само підлягала
нижченню Отже українська мова багато на
визначення поплічники
примусове співпраця як це вживають
поляки оскільки визначення стосовно
історії України
часів Другої світової війни прийняттю
але те що стосується Європи там звичайно
ми можемо скажімо у випадках Франції
застосовувати визначення колаборації
колабораціонізму оцінка перебування
України у складі студентського суду
звичайно
різнопланова інформація тут у нас є але
все-таки ми повинні чітко усвідомити що
для України перебування у складі
советского союзу було злом
якщо людське життя найвище тіні якщо ми
подивимося на величезні втрати українців
і на те що весь процес перебування в
Україні в складі Советского Союзу був
позначений прагненнями зупинити процес
українського нації творення то звичайно
наші діти повинні чітко усвідомлювати що
перебування України у складі
студентського союзу було для України
злом а розподільського Союзу був
абсолютно закономірним явищем І отут ми
з вами знову повертаємося до усього
всесвітнього головної всесвітньої
тенденції тобто 20 століття розпад
імперії повстання національних держав А
що ж це як
Советский Союз чув абсолютно
історичному процесу Чому Тому що
Подивіться після Першої світової війни
розпад імперій Советский Союз
створюється яким Імперія після Другої
Світової просто колоніальних імперій а
союзників Союз підтягнув до себе ще й
країни Центральної і Східної Європи Чому
через терор через свою тоталітарну
сутність Отже знову Висновок про те що
розпадського Союзу не був геополітичною
катастрофою або в закономірним явищем і
закономірності в історичному процесі
значить
рисування одна хвилина Я просто хочу
просто вже завершити ми витратили досить
багато часу і на те щоб
виокремити окремий розділ які стосуються
європейського вибору України і
російсько-української війни
тепер наші діти будуть системно вивчати
це питання передумови характер цієї
війни як загарбницької опріалістичної
несправедливої
консолідацію нашого громадянського
суспільства і завершив свій виступ я
основною головною тезою в наших
програмах тепер людина
громадянське суспільство - це
найважливіший стрижень які ми всі наші
програми і всі історичні процеси які ми
в нас радикально різницю від
Російської імперії Російської Федерації
де
не Держава працює в ім'я людини а
навпаки людина гвинтик в системі
державної машини Дуже дякую вам колеги
та пані людмило Дуже дякую всій робочій
групі і особисто вам за тут титанічну
роботу яку ви провели оновлюючі програми
я хочу сказати скільки нас організатори
вже дуже
обмежують в часі
Шановні колеги Слідкуйте будь ласка за
оголошеннями на сайті Міністерства
освіти і науки України ми вже як
говорили анонсувала пані Людмила
Гриневич спільно з робочою групою
спільно з керівником робочої групи
людмилою Гриневич
запланували кілька вебінарів які будуть
стосуватися
програмних восьмих класів 9-го класу
окремо 10-11 всесвітньої історії тому
будь ласка Ми всі посилання на ці нашу
вебінари будемо давати на сайті
Міністерство освіти і науки України
Слідкуйте за цим А програми як уже
сказала пані Світлана фіцайло розміщені
знов-таки на міністерському сайті Дуже
дякуємо і на цьому завершуємо роботу
нашої секції історія правознавства і
громадянської освіти Спасибі великі
Шановні колеги всіх з новим навчальним
роком Слава Україні
Героям слава
Героям слава Героям слава на роботу Дуже
дякуємо вам з роботи
Героям слава
можеш мені виступити
[музика]
Добрий день Добрий день шановні колеги
розпочинаємо роботу секції
мовно-літературна освіта і прошу зараз
приєднатися вчителі української мови
зарубіжної літератури українська
література вчителі методистів історії
інших предметів якщо вам це не актуально
популярності
[музика]
І про що зараз
приєднатись
Шановні колеги велике прохання вимкнути
мікрофони щоб це не заважало нам і час
нашої роботи
Тож сьогодні під час нашої роботи ми
звертаємо увагу на зміни що відбуваються
зарубіжної літератури для
6-11 класів саме особливості вивчення
української мови української літератури
любі української школи велике прохання
вимкнути мікрофоністю чекаємо нашу думку
але Шановні колеги сказала запрошую як
мікрофоном
[музика]
перше питання яке
озвучити за допомогою своїх колег це
зміни відбулися у програмі і зарубіжної
літератури для 5-9 класів 10-11 класів
профільного рівня та рівня стандарту
вони пов'язані саме агресії Росії війну
яка розпочалася
саме вилучення твору
із навчальною програмою це питання
розглядалося на засіданні робочої групи
також
встановлення навчальних програм методом
з літератури зарубіжна та українська де
одностайно було вирішено ці форми
російські вилучити з програми Для
детального
аналізу зміни що відбулися в програмі і
в зарубіжна література Я запрошую голову
робочий
доктора філологічних наук професора
завідувача кафедри світової літератури
Полтавського національного педагогічного
університету імені Короленка
будь ласка Ольга Миколаївна
Добрий день шановні колеги я Всіх вітаю
і Тема моєї доповіді предмет Зарубіжна
література в аспекті реалізації сучасних
міжнародних стратегій України динаміка
змін я Сердечно вітаю вас у нашому
професійному колі Бажаю міцного здоров'я
безпеки і сили для зміцнення нашого
освітнього фронту рятувати допомагати
навчати зберігати і боротися ось ключові
слова нашого драматичного і
сьогодення ми з вами бійці духовного
фронту і саме ми не лише тримаємо
оборону а й укріплюємо дух нашої нації
на шляху до перемоги України в цій
страшній війні дуже важливо
найкращі книжки світу які допомагають
нашим учням морально вижити і вистояти
нація яка читає непереможна
сьогодні нас у боротьбі за свободу
підтримує цілий світ міжнародні
стратегії України полягають у подальшому
просуванні до Євросоюзу у розвитку
міцних взаємин із передовими країнами
світу і у побудові нової системи безпеки
де Україна і цивілізований світ будуть
єдиним цілим як же зміцнити наші
стосунки з цивілізованими країнами один
із певних шляхів - це вивчати мови
культури літератури цих країн долучатися
до їхніх духовних скарбів які допоможуть
нам бути сильнішими і стійкішими предмет
зарубіжної літератури нині єднає довкола
себе не лише українських дітей і
вчителів а й людей доброї волі усього
світу з допомогою предмета зарубіжна
література ми можемо зараз спілкуватися
з усім світом зрозумілою для всіх мовою
загальнолюдських цінностей із перших
місяців війни Я і Мої колеги вчителі
Наталія Рудницька і ві одиниця працювали
у всеукраїнській школі онлайн
Щотижня ми виходили прямий ефір на
онлайн уроки для дітей які постраждали
від війни із Маріуполя Харкова Попасною
та інших міст і селищ на ці онлайн
заняття бо нас приєднувалися науковці
вчителі діти письменників з інших країн
зі Швеції Німеччини Польщі та інших і
вони передавали підтримку нашим
українським школярам і розповідали про
книжки які є знаковими для цих країн які
вивчають у нас У нашому шкільному курсі
зарубіжної літератури на цих онлайн
уроках і зарубіжної літератури Наші учні
відчували духовне єднання з усім світом
Нещодавно я повернулася із Данії де була
з робочим візитом і ми обговорювали із
нашими міжнародними партнерами із
Євросоюзу а також зі Сполучених Штатів
Америки Японії новий цикл занять для
своїх учнів Нові заходи із зарубіжної
літератури які допоможуть морально
вплинути на наших виробництва Я думаю що
із вересня ви всі побачите і я думаю що
це буде нове нове дихання для зарубіжної
літератури
ой предмет Зарубіжна література сучасній
школі предмет який в умовах війни дає
нашим дітям духовний досвід інших
народів А ще відчуття причетності до
цивілізованого світу це предмет який нас
єднає і з усім світом але Жоден із
навчальних предметів не стоїть на місці
змінюється час і змінюється зміст і
технології викладання тому предмет
зарубіжної літератури який народився
разом із нашою Незалежності має свою
історію і свою динаміку Сьогодні ми
обговорюємо зміни до програм із
зарубіжної літератури 2022 року Але
маємо на увазі що це колишній програми
створені під державний стандарт 2011
року вони поступово будуть відходити без
1 вересня стартує нова українська школа
наразі створено нові модельні програми
для 5-6 і для п'ятих дев'ятих класів
відповідно до державного стандарту 2020
року у них інший зміст інша структура
але ці програми що залишаються чинними з
шостого класу відіграли і відіграють
вагому роль умовно-літературній освіті
свого часу вони стали новим кроком у
розвитку предмета зарубіжна література
чому а тому що по-перше це були програми
які вперше пройшли громадські
обговорення в
2015-2016-2017 року на відкритій
платформі Едера і 2022 року це означає
що суспільство цікаво зарубіжна
література це означає що суспільство
бере активну участь у розвитку предмета
зарубіжна література по-друге вперше
саме в цих програмах було запроваджено
розділ сучасна література який наблизив
наших учнів до сучасного світу нині ми
вже не уявляємо нашого курса без творів
Роальда Дала Міхаеля Енде Річарда Баха
Крістіни Нестлінгер Барбари космовської
та багатьох інших але ще кілька років
тому ми
навчалися про них по-третє у цих
програмах за основний Вектор було взято
твори для дітей і про дітей менше
дорослої класики але більше про людські
стосунки вільне мислення фантазію
людяність по четверте саме в цих
програмах і зарубіжної літератури вперше
з'явився варіативний компонент що
забезпечує академічну роботу і
академічну свободу вчителів відтоді
стало можливим вибирати той чи інший
твір для вивчення близько 25% творів ми
тоді винесли на альтернативне вивчення і
це зробило програми гнучкими їх можна
було адаптувати відповідно до інтересів
школярів та вчителів по п'яте у цих
програмах з'явилися рубрики Україна і
світ елементи компаративістиків що
дозволили посилити україноцентричний
Вектор вивчення зарубіжної літератури по
шостий структурі програми було закладено
не лише жанрово-тематичний і
хронологічний принципи а й концентричний
принцип навчання Що дозволило важкі для
відкриття учнів твори перенести в старші
класи і зробити викладання зарубіжної
літератури легшим і цікавішим і
письмовому цих програмах було
акцентовано рух України до Євросоюзу
навіть епіграф із гімну Євросоюзу і
водночас збільшену відсоток творів із
інших континентів і країн зауважують що
курс зарубіжної літератури викладається
виключно українською мовою із часів його
заснування твори зарубіжної літератури
вивчається якісних українських
перекладах
трохи статистики щодо частки російської
літератури в цих програмах про те що
було І що тепер стало в процесі змін
2022 року про п'ятий клас Ми не говоримо
бо з 1 вересня п'ятикласники будуть
навчатися за новими модельними
програмами зокрема програмою школа
радості де немає жодного російського
твору Також я не говорю про список
творів для додаткового читання тому що
саме це вибір і можна було не брати
ніякого російського твору говоримо
тільки про основне читання у програмі
для шостих-9 класів основний читання
було вміщено понад 140 творів з Європи
Азії Америки Африки це понад 70
письменників із 25 країн які ж російські
автори були в основному читанні в
програмі для шостих-9 класів це 10
авторів із них 5 за вибором тобто 6-9
класах обов'язково і текстуально вивчали
раніше 5 авторів 19 століття Крилов
Пушкін Лермонтов Гоголь і Чехов маємо на
увазі що Гоголь український письменник
ще 5 авторів за вибором Короленко
Булгаков Олександр Грін вірш Костянтина
Симонова і повість сучасної авторки
Марини аромштам відсоток ви можете
порахувати самі у програмах для 10-11
класів рівень стандартної профільний
було близько 45 дворнів із 23 країн тут
представлені такі континенти як Європа
Америка Азія і вперше з'явилася
Австралія які російські автори були
обов’язковими до вивчення в програмах
для 10-11 класів їх було лише 4 рівень
стандарту Булгаков Майстер і Маргарита
Достоєвський Злочин і кара а також
Тютчев і Фет в огляді чистого мистецтва
у профільному рівні були ще Мертві душі
Гоголя тобто в профільному рівні 5
і ще 4 автори в основній програмі були
запропоновані за вибором Тобто їх можна
було вивчати або не вивчати це блок
Ахматова Пастернак Маяковський Отже із
45 творів лише 4 або 5 були
обов'язковоми для текстуального вивчення
24 лютого 2022 року Все змінило все
перевернуло в нашому житті у всіх сферах
суспільства зокрема в освіті і спочатку
агресія і Всеросійське стало викликати
великий біль і страждання зокрема в
українських дітей трагічні події
спонукали до зібрання круглого столу 7
квітня 2022 року за участі науковців і
вчителів щодо перегляду місця російської
літератури в курсі зарубіжної літератури
на тому круглому столі були озвучені
заяви громадських організацій
українського асоціації викладачів
зарубіжної літератури і всеукраїнської
спілки вчителів словесників ці заяви
стали підставою для наказу Міністерства
освіти і науки України від 3 червня 2022
року номер 521 про утворення робочих
груп зановлені змісту навчальних програм
на доновленням програми із зарубіжної
літератури працювала велика робоча група
це було 10 фахівців із вищих навчальних
закладів і середніх навчальних закладів
до якої долучилися що 10 представників
органів державної влади
громадського преси з усіма я дякую всім
і кожному і також дякую з осіб на
народному депутату секретареві комітету
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти
науки та інновації Наталії романівні
піпів 13 червня 2022 року протокол №2
робоча група прийняла рішення яке було
ухвалено одностайно і опубліковано в
засобах масової інформації було
запропоновано вилучити та або замінити
твори всіх російських і одного
білоруського письменників а твори Гоголя
і кримськотатарського письменника таіра
халілова перенести до програми з
української літератури рішення робочої
групи підтримала експертна комісія з
літератури української зарубіжної
Міністерство освіти і науки України 12
липня 2022 року а 25 липня 2022 року
Міністерстві освіти і науки України
відбулися відбулися нарада на якій були
присутні Міністр освіти і науки України
представників Міністерства народні
депутати представники Національної
академії наук інституту літератури
інституту історії і президент
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України на цій наразі також обговорювали
питання щодо вивчення творів російських
письменників у курсі зарубіжної
літератури але обговорення йшло лише
стосовно тих митців які були пов'язані з
своїм життям і творчістю з України на
сьогодні Міністерство освіти і науки
України прийняло психологічне рішення
затверджене відповідним наказом номер
698 яке це рішення воно переважно
врахувало думку громадськості понад 90%
пропозицій робочої групи враховано через
збройну агресію Російської Федерації
щодо України та відсутність рецептивного
контексту майже всі твори російських і
білоруського письменників вилучені або
замінені на такі що відповідають віковим
особливостям учнів та з урахуванням
літературного контексту у шостому класі
байки Крилова замінено на байкулефонтена
зачомлені звірі оповідання Чехова
замінені на твори О Генрі Вождь
червоношкірих або сучасної французької
авторки Анни гавальди 35 кіло надії один
за вибором у сьомому класі замість
билини про Іллю муромця і Соловей
розбійника учні будуть більше читати
англійські народні балади про Робіна
Гуда не одну а дві балади вірш була та
Окуджави До побачення хлопчики у
вибірковому читанні замінено на вірш
вайсбусах руки теж у вибірковому читанні
альпійську баладу Василя Бикова замінили
твори сучасних письменників з Ірландії
Джон бойн хлопчик у смугастій піжамі та
з Франції
Шмідт діти Ноя замість вірша Пушкіна 19
жовтня 1825 року діти будуть більше
читати поетичних творів про кохання і
дружбу і це твори зарубіжних поетів Цей
список розширено список і був але він
просто значно розширений нині замість
пурпурових вітрил у гірковому читанні
з'явився ульф Старк маленька книжка про
любов і Диваки і зануди один твір за
вибором вірш Симонова Жди мене вилучено
з переліку вибіркових творів з метою
розвантаження програми так само у
восьмому класі вилучено двір сучасної
авторки Марини аромштамп коли відпочи
називають янголи із вибіркового
компонента у 9-му класі замість творів
Пушкіна і Лермонтова учні будуть читати
європейські романи і створено
відповідний розділ нові обрії
європейського роману Джейн Остін
Гордість та упередження від торгів Собор
Паризької Богоматері Шарлотта Бронте
джейнр
Джозеф Конрад серце пітьми один твір за
вибором учителя у 10-му класі знято
огляд творчості Тютчева Роман Злочин і
кара Достоєвського як важкі для
сприйняття також важкі для сприйняття
був твір Алхімік Пауло Коельйо його
також знято з вивчення в 11 класі роман
Майстер і Маргарита Булгакова замінимо
на роман Чума Альбера Камю знятою з
вибіркового читання твори блока
Ахматової Пастернака і Маяковського
оскільки програми з української
літератури не змінюються нині твори
Миколи Гоголя 6 і 9 класах а також
Володимир Короленко в шостому класі і
таіра халілова в 11-му класі залишаються
в програмі і зарубіжної літератури але
лише твори Гоголя Ніч перед Різдвом у 6
класі і Шинель і Ревізор у дев'ятому
класі є обов'язковими для вивчення у
10-му класі для профільного рівня Мертві
душі Миколи Гоголя як важкий для
сприйняття твір було замінено на Роман
канадського письменниці
Енн із Зелених Дахів цей роман передував
роману Полліанна Елеонор Портер твір
Короленка Сліпий музикант твір Короленка
Сліпий музикант твір про шлях до мети
людини з особливими потребами
передбачено у варіативному компоненті
для шостого класу на вибір поруч із
творами Гаррієт бічер-стоу Хатина дядька
Тома і ульфа Старка чи вмієш ти свистати
югано проставлення до людей похилого
віку тут аж три це на вибір Короленко
бічер-стоу і Старк
у варіативному компоненті програми для
шостих-9 класів у 9 класі відповідно до
рішення мон є Собаче серце Булгакова тут
запропоновано за вибором із 5 1 2 твори
шолом-алейхем тев'є-молочар Булгаков
Собаче серце Рей Дуглас Бредбері 451
градус за Фаренгейтом Гарпер Лі Убити
пересмішника Ерік сігел Історія одного
кохання учителі мають широкий вибір що
стосується твору Майстер і Маргарита
Булгакова Та як я сказала його замінено
на твір Чума Альбера Камю відбулися
зміни в списку творів для додаткового
читання майже всі твори російської
літератури вилучено залишилися твори
Бабин Яр Анатолія Кузнецова у дев'ятому
класі як такий що стосується історичних
подій які відбувалися в Україні на
пропозицію народного депутата Наталії
піпе Додано для додаткового читання в
десятому класі ще два актуальні твори
Йозеф ро марш радецького і Олександр
гранах Ось іде людина це також на вибір
учителя наказом міністерства освіти і
науки України прийнято рішення також
залишити в списку для додаткового
читання для 11 класу твір Ільфа і
Петрова 12 стільців це також за вибором
учителя по факту із тих персоналів що
залишилися обов'язково ми для вивчення є
тільки твори Миколи Гоголя решта на
вибір учителя який має певну академічну
свободу на завершення скажу що немає
ідеальних навчальних програм будь-яка
програма перевіряється практикою тому
практика і досвід учителів це найкращий
критерій оцінки будь-якої програми після
війни ми ще раз переглянемо наші
програми ми іще раз подумаємо обговоримо
ми розберемося які твори російської
білоруської літератури будуть потрібні в
школі як як вивчати якщо вони ще будуть
потрібні ми побачимо все після війни
після салюту перемоги А наразі ми маємо
наказ Міністерства освіти і науки
України номер 698 який дає повну
академічну свободу нашим учителям Я дуже
вірю в наших учителів вони мудрі Вони
знають що треба робити І що буде
найкраще для українських учнів Дякую за
увагу Слава Україні
[музика]
літератури в новій українській школі
компетентністю потенціал це
цю тему
порушуйте Міла Яценко головний науковий
співробітник відділу навчання
української мови та літератури інституту
педагогіки Національної академії
педагогічних наук України будь Практично
на Таміла Олексіївна запрошую вас до
слова
Добрий день шановні колеги як уже
сказала Олена Юріївна Тема мого виступу
навчання української літератури в новій
українській школі і хочу я саме
зупинитися на компетентнісну потенціалі
нового навчального методичного
забезпечення яке підготовлене в
інституті педагогіки Олена Юріївна мені
треба демонстрація екрана я можу просто
заходити
колеги просто заходили Чи вам клас не
пускають нічого вона не включається
зараз я все з допомогою
де тут начать все А ось Вже пішло
Я ваша презентація
Шановні колеги як ви вже знаєте я
безперечно переконана що ви ознайомилися
вже з новими навчальними програмами а
саме з програми української літератури
ви знаєте що мета
навчання української літератури в новій
українській школі це формування
компетентних учнів читачів і програма
яка підготовлена авторським колективом
інституту педагогіки вона спрямована на
формування компетентних учнів читачів
набуття наскрізних умінь читацький
особистісний розвиток школярів програма
має
компетентність на
спрямування яке досягається шляхом
розкриття можливостей предмета для
формування як предметної читацької
компетентності так і ключових
компетентностей
програма
по складається з таких компонентів як
очікування результати пропонований зміст
курсу і види навчальної дії
змістове наповнення рубрики очікування
результати як інтегрований результат
шкільної літературної освіти тобто знань
умінь навичок читацьку досвіду і
ціннісних ставлень корелює і сутністю як
ключових так і предметно читацької
компетентності
очікування результату навчання вони
скорильовані і з чотирма групами умінь
які задекларовані в державному стандарті
загальної середньої освіти тобто перша
група результатів - це усна Взаємодія це
слухання аудіювання друга - це
сприймання аналіз інтерпретація критичне
оцінювання інформації в текстах різних
видів це читання Третє - це
висловлювання тобто говоріння і четверта
- це власне мовна творчість - це письмо
Вибачте слайди не звертаються
слайди не гортаються на презентацію на
ваші
Як це зробити щоб
режим на картинці тільки не відкрито
презентація тобто з боковою панелькою де
висять робочі
О ось так видно да так будь ласка
читацька компетентність визначення її
вона прописана в нашій програмі я не
буду зараз зупинятися на цьому питанні
власне Я хочу зупинитись на питання
формування ключових компетентностей за
допомогою
підручника української літератури який
підготовлений авторським колективом
інституту педагогіки підручник цей
пройшов успішно Пілот 5 класах і має
гриф Міністерства освіти
принцип побудови підручника це читацько
чи центричний і текстоцентричний і от
саме засобами підручника є вчитель має
можливість формувати ключові
компетентності От наприклад перша
ключова компетентність яка прописана в
державному стандарті відповідно в
концепцію нової української школи - це
вільне володіння державною мовою
Наприклад ми даємо таке завдання В нас є
рубрика мовна скарбничка і в процесі
вивчення
фольклору Ми даємо завдання пригадай що
таке пряме та переносне значення слова
зверни увагу що у прислів'ях і приказках
вживається як у прямому так і в
переносному значенні Наведи приклади
використання слів у творах малих жанрів
фольклору в різних значеннях або ж
або ж пригадай що таке прикметники яке
значення мають прикметники знайди так в
тексті казки лелія прикметники за
допомогою яких Леся Українка передає
красу квітів впродовж це динамічний ряд
прикметників бачите ви на презентації
наступна ключова компетентність - це
здатність спілкуватися рідною мовою в
разі відмінності від державної та
іноземними мовами наприклад в ті ж самі
рубриці мовна скарбничка яка в нас є
усталеною
рубрикою в процесі вивчення всіх
навчальних тем ми пропонуємо у темі яка
присвячена вивченню оповідання сучасної
української письменниці Марії Морозенко
вірність Хатіко учням таке завдання із
тексту оповідання ти дізнався що слово
хатів в перекладі з японської означає
восьмий це ім'я стало символом вірності
відомості своєму другові
цікаво що в українській мові є наприклад
50 слів запозичених японським от як
наприклад і даємо ці приклади звернись
до словника іншомовних слів і довідайся
які ще слова мають японська походження
наступна компетентність математична так
в процесі вивчення української
літератури вчитель має можливість також
формувати математичну компетентність на
її
що це що вона передбачає це застосування
математичних знань та методів для
розважання широкого спектра проблем у
повсякденному житті От наприклад в
процесі вивчення
першої вступної теми про значення
літератури і книги в житті книжки в
житті людини ми даємо учням таке
завдання
Пригадай з яких частин складається
книжка
пригадати з яких частин складається
книжка тобі допоможе схема або ж
переважно Розглянь схему ознаки народної
казки та прокоментуй кожну з ознак
прикладами сад
т
з проблемами
так
звисла презентація зависло все зараз
Шановні колеги спробуємо
Таміла Олексіївна знаходиться від Києва
на певній кількості сотні кілометрів
тому так виходить Мабуть її вибило
Так там попереджали що можливі будуть
проблеми з інтернетом Шановні колеги
якщо щоб ми зараз не гаяли час бо в нас
його дуже обмаль до теми літератури і
саме
особливості вивчення української
літератури Ми повернемося коли Таміла
Олексіївна з'явиться у нас знову тут в
ефірі А зараз я хочу надати слово ми до
теми літератури повернемося саме
Ользі миколаївні олені миколаївні
горошки олені миколаївні горошкіни яка
саме порушить питання вивчення
української мови в новій українській
школі і будь ласка Олена Миколаївна
завідувач відео навчальної навчання
української мови та літератури інституту
педагогіки Національної академії наук
України
Олена Миколаївна ви тут Я тут з вами
Дякую Олена правильно я теж готувала
презентацію але боюся вже її включати як
його краще зробити
тому що інтернет теж не стійкий Шановні
колеги я спробую але буду говорити щоб
не витрачати час я дуже рада бачити вас
усіх і поговорити про зміни в Нових
програмах які було запроваджено оскільки
1 вересня
починається
нова українська школа уже не в плотних
закладах а вже починається для широкого
загалу
Я розумію що є тривоги є різноманітні
якісь знаєте побоювання як воно
відбудеться оскільки нові програми
оскільки нові підручники Ну і нові умови
навчання або все-таки війна є війна і
тут
ясно що вона не сприяє тому що ми могли
говорити про повноцінну і освітній
процес Скажіть будь ласка добре
презентацію чи ні
видно але трохи видно видно
було розроблення програм я не буду довго
говорити оскільки з'явився новий
стандарт і він знаєте враховує якісь
соціальні виклики виклики і орієнтує на
нові результати ставить нову метою
мовно-літературно-освітньої галузі є
формування розвиток компетентних мов і
читачів То необхідно було розробити
програму яка буде спрямована на